[Laughter]
foreign
hey you guys what's going on yes Friday
night yep we're gonna try to get you
guys ready for the weekend we're getting
ready to relax with some drinks yeah we
bought a whole stash of stuff
got a new uh brand uh we went to ABC
Liquors and I got a new brand of uh
what is that rum two different flavors
of that show them that yeah
we've never had this brand before we
thought it looked kind of cool yeah
that's called Palms Tropical Palms yeah
I think that's what pineapple that's
pineapple and the other one is just a
Caribbean Caribbean rum and then um
yeah
and then I got um
two jars of uh moonshine yeah
and uh they came recommended one of them
is apple pie which we had that before
that shit's [ __ ] good yeah we got
like the little sample last time it
comes in big jar like jars like it
should yeah and uh yeah it comes in
mason jars and uh the other one is uh
it's um
pralines and cream really no it's butter
pecan butter pecan okay all right I was
like you know we gotta get that yeah it
looked good they didn't have like it
took me a while to find
um the Moonshine and they don't have a
lot because they just had like some just
on the bottom but yeah they had the
apple pie they had the butter pecan and
then they had three different brands but
yeah they had like moonshine cherries
yeah and moonshine pickles they had
whole pickles and whole cherries in it
yeah like pickle spears and I was kind
of peach oh that's right they did have
peach tea yeah with peaches
it had canned peaches floating in it
yeah
it's probably [ __ ] good though it's
probably really I'm not a huge Peach fan
but yeah it's probably I'm sure it's
good it's probably like peach pie it's
probably good I was very excited about
that butter pecan one I was like you
know we have to get that I mean it was
super expensive what was it was like 19
bucks for a jar a jar yeah like 19. 18 I
think 18.99 that's 19 yeah but yeah but
you know it's
that apple pie was so good though yeah
I don't know how yeah I can make it
I would buy it still yeah it was still
up there yeah you just can't sell the
[ __ ] well yeah you can make it yeah if
you're just making it for yourself it's
not hard but I can make it it's okay I
just don't know what they're using for
flavoring
but um
yeah maybe I'll buy us maybe I'll buy us
a moonshine still
that up in the kitchen
and just make my own because you
basically needs sugar a corn corn I
think is what it is a couple different
ways to do flavors it's it's it's
moonshine's not as not as hard as I mean
you can make moonshine real hard if you
want you can make it basically Ever
Clear
but they don't do that it's not as hard
as Everclear but it's harder than vodka
yeah usually
everybody's wishing me happy birthday
thank you this is gonna be like a
pre-birthday because my actual birthday
is Monday
so we're gonna we were like doing
research last night because I said I
kind of want to go out like for lunch
you know and but I want to go to a place
we haven't gone yet
you know what I mean because like I love
I love Momiji like the Japanese place
but I was like we always go there I
think you even went there for your
birthday because that's where you wanted
to go I was like I want to go somewhere
different I want to try something else
we found a place yeah what the [ __ ] is
the name of that place something rather
me magnificent meat Boutique Boutique
and it's British it's a British pub so
they have like Steak and Ale pie and
[ __ ] full English and full English
with the [ __ ] beans and everything we
had the black pudding yeah they're like
all and I'm not having that but you got
a lamb burger yeah everything looks
really good and it got like really good
uh ratings and it's only about 10 miles
from here yeah it looks nice in the
inside yeah and I was like ooh that
looks like fun let's go do that they got
the damn Tardis in there
yeah they have like all the British
paraphernalia it's it's a it's a call
box yeah it's like the call box so they
all look like that yeah no they're all
red yeah all of their phones the Tardis
wasn't red the target well I know the
Tardis I'm just saying that all of their
all of those all of the phone booths are
red yeah you know so it's not a police
call box it's a damn phone booth yeah
it's a phone booth I mean I'm sure you
don't see them over there anymore they
don't have small boots here anymore yeah
I don't think I can't remember the last
time Booth here because why the [ __ ]
would anybody since I was a kid you know
except for like emergency ones on the
side of the highway maybe they don't
even have them for crackheads anymore
yeah everybody got to have a cell phone
even crackheads have cell phones okay
well you know you can get in cell phones
for cheap nowadays you just go to
Walmart and get like those burner phones
yeah 20 bucks I think
John Smith said to be a real English pub
you need a sense of inflated ego and
quiet despair yeah we'll see I mean we
probably got that covered I would
imagine that we'll see what it's like I
used to go to like a really it wasn't a
pub it was actually like an English tea
room yeah uh in Daytona it's it was
really small but they had like really
really nice food in there and you could
actually like buy British countries in
there before you could buy them at
Publix because most most Publix is at
least in in this area of Florida they
have like a little section where you can
buy British groceries like there's a few
shelves of it we'll make a video when we
get there yeah we should it's just like
it looks really good because I was like
I kind of want like steak but there's
not really a steakhouse within like
25-30 miles of here that was a long hot
there's a longhorn yeah but that's 27
miles away it is the closest one is it
that far yeah it's far okay so I was
just kind of like well I don't really
want to go all that far but then so we
found this place and I was like well
that sounds pretty good so that's where
we're gonna go and I'm gonna get a damn
I'm gonna get a damn Publix cake yeah so
I gotta look and see because maybe I'm
just gonna get fish and chips I think
yeah we're already like thinking about
what we're gonna get so we're gonna go
actual Monday but yeah Monday's my
actual birthday so like I said we're
gonna have to do because that's a
haunting day so we'll have to like have
a haunting that has to we'll do like a
birthday haunting episode two people got
in there or something like that all
right are they starting to show up John
Smith said you still get red phone
booths in historical City centers and
blue police boxes in Scotland so that's
what it is I remember seeing some when I
was there but it's been a long time so
let me go get this uh let me go get them
oh he's gonna go get the Moonshine I
took a picture of it earlier and like
put it in the community Tab and I put it
on Facebook as well because
yeah I didn't take a picture like we
have we have a big jar of the apple pie
moonshine the Moonshine that we got last
time to you but I didn't really like I
just put that in the back because I was
like well we already showed that on the
last show I was just excited about the
butter pecan one but it was like I don't
know it was really hard to find the ABC
that's not I mean it's not that close
it's probably you know seven or eight
miles from here but um it's really nice
I was I was impressed we were actually
gonna get some more of that pumpkin chai
uh ale or whatever it was because that
[ __ ] was really good but then we were
like man that's like 14 just for like
four of them and maybe we should get
something that we haven't had before
because we've already had those although
I did like them that pumpkin Nitro that
had like the cold brew coffee in it
I think I just drank the last one of
those last night I don't know how many
were in the box I think it was just four
there you go yes we actually we're doing
small glasses this time we're not crazy
I'm not I'm doing a small jar what I'm
getting a small jar that's our thing
that's the 13 o'clock jar that's right
that's a great moonshine Charlie yeah
that's good I totally forgot I got that
so this is it this is the Moonshine
I mean look at that that looks luscious
a little smoky yeah oh Smokey what's it
say that with the glasses on I'm gonna
read all this he's gonna read all this
there's all kinds of [ __ ] I paid good
money for this we gonna read it that's
what I mean that better be worth 19 okay
man my glasses are [ __ ] up it says
some old smokey what to say moonshine
yeah but here you could probably read it
better than me these are your glasses
and they don't [ __ ] her that's off
the show those are my glasses
butter pecan moonshine let me see it's
dark in here though yeah no it's too
dark I can't read [ __ ] because it's like
it's dark red text on black we Blended
our moonshine with the delicious flavors
of butter cream toasted pecans and
caramel all right liquid Heaven it says
welcome judge of that all right
um
oh and oh butter pecan wake up call
that's a little drink that they have
like a recipe for it's cream colored
that'd be two ounces of this stuff two
espresso shots and five ounces of
steamed milk garnish with whipped cream
and caramel sauce
[ __ ] yeah
oh man
and on the back it says come on live a
little
I I don't even want a green color how
many calories this is probably a lot but
I'm just gonna have oh my God that's
most delightful wow oh it smells so good
you guys it's too bad this like this
show isn't scratch and sniff oh man are
we gonna get in trouble oh yeah we're
gonna get in trouble
oh man
it's like real strong Bailey's Irish
Cream but it's [ __ ] ice cream
flavored oh my God and with um that's
delicious [ __ ] it's got a million
calories oh my God
yeah it's got to be that good I'm sure
this right here is probably the best I
like um it's so good though
um
it's kind of like Bailey's Irish Cream
it does yeah that's it does taste a bit
like Bailey's but it's um but it's got
like kind of a Nutty caramel kind of
almost like peanut brittle on the back
end yeah which I'm guessing that's like
the caramel or whatever
yeah that oh my God that's so good
it's a good thing that's 19 because
otherwise I'd be going down there and
buying that [ __ ] all the time and I'll
get [ __ ] fat
that's what that's really really good
though it has the consistency of melted
ice cream
uh it's kind of thick it's like melted
ice cream
and moonshine like you spiked it
pretty good yeah real good definitely a
dessert flavor
I don't know if that's right here it's a
dessert wine is that what it what no
sorry that was from Greece I just
remembered that because they're drinking
wine with Twinkies right yeah
I'm sorry you should know that by now I
just randomly remember like movie quotes
like yeah I didn't know something else
yeah
that was from the movie yeah from Greece
I didn't remember when they were at the
when they were at the um slumber party I
didn't notice what they were talking
about yeah
because they were like they were getting
all over Jan's case because she had
twinkies and they were like Twinkies and
wine girls this would probably get you
slammed
oh how many proof is that could you find
out
what to say on it
okay so I'm so I'm klutzy so I don't
want to drink I don't want to drop it
okay it says but holy [ __ ] that's small
okay so I'm really really it doesn't
taste that strong to me it's not that
strong I don't think it says 17.
17.9 I think that's what it said
so about 30 proof 30 proof for 35 proof
I can't really read it so it's maybe
it's 33. it's about like 35. it's about
like Bailey Cyrus cream yeah it's not
super strong it's not like I feel like
the apple pie one I feel like that was
so strong it was really really strong
even though that was also very delicious
but this one is just yeah but like I'm
glad that we just have like small
glasses because yeah that's probably
super fattening I mean just when I saw
that I was like we'll just have just
that I'll we'll save that yeah well yeah
that's that's one that we're gonna have
to like Savor yeah so you can just have
like a little bit at a time I couldn't
drink that it feels like a [ __ ]
holiday well like I said it's got well
it's kind of like a holiday because
because like you know uh you know my
birthday's on Monday and it's also now
officially fall which I'm very excited
even though it's still kind of hot here
although we went out earlier we would we
had to go to Lowe's and we went to the
liquor store which are right across the
street from each other and um it was
actually not it wasn't cool but it
wasn't punishing so that was something
like when we went outside I was like hey
it doesn't make me want to kill myself
out here and it was kind of Cloudy which
was nice too still hot but not that bad
not that bad
yeah Danny Rowling said it looks like a
white russian that looks like a tasty
beverage it is a tasty yeah
but like I said I couldn't drink this
all night well no yeah it'd be like I
said this is one that you really yeah
drink like a little bit of like a
holiday because it's very it's very very
sweet but it's good though I would put
it very similar to Bailey's Irish Cream
but it's just a different flavor it's
I would say it was
um well it's pecan and caramel yeah so
you don't yeah it's better tastes like
butter pecan ice cream it does yeah
that's been melted and spiked yeah
but yeah that's uh that's delicious
delicious should be expensive we also it
kind of I couldn't I actually forgot
like I thought it was one of the ones
that was on sale but then like when we
went back to see how much it was I was
like oh my God that shit's 19. yeah we
drank half of that already
well you know
oh you know it's interesting when we
were in there because I was like looking
around because you know I'm a graphic
designer so I like to look at all the
bottle designs and stuff because I love
like liquor bottle designs
um and I noticed that they sell the
stuff from the Saint Augustine
distillery in there because remember I
told you they have a big Distillery they
make ramen gin and scotch and bourbon or
whatever
um and everything like right in St
Augustine and I was gonna do a tour of
it but I didn't have time I just went I
toured like the outside but I didn't go
inside and they actually sell it in
there and holy [ __ ] that shit's
expensive I think the one
what was was it the bourbon
that's like top shelf so it was like 55
for a fifth yeah and I was like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] that better be some good
that better be some good stuff like all
their [ __ ] was expensive man it's
difficult it's difficult to [ __ ]
compete with just the regular big
American brands right now
I mean Jim beams got some fantastic [ __ ]
they're just giving it away and same
with like Bacardi rum and yeah they had
actually they had gym beam orange which
I don't think I've ever had before and I
think they were it was everything was on
sale so I think it was only like 13.99
and Jack Daniels offers like about 30
different products
different kinds of Jack Daniels [ __ ]
going from Rock gut up to [ __ ] 100 a
bottle nice [ __ ] you know and then just
like their regular twenty dollars A
fifth or ten dollars a fifth you know
whatever
they got like
honey flavors and
cinnamon type flavor whiskey it's just
the flavors are fantastic I really
actually I quite I quite like the Jack
Daniels it's Jack Daniel's Honey right I
quite like that somebody gave me that
for Christmas a few years ago and I
thought it was delicious
John Smith said uh saw a shop selling
Christmas stuff today which is a thing
yeah we went to Lowe's today I bought a
weed eater to get uh yeah like a like a
weed eater thing because our other one
broke and um yeah all their Christmas
trees are out they have like their big
Halloween you know Inflatables but it's
[ __ ] because the Halloween
inflatables are all way up the [ __ ] by
the ceiling because I didn't even see
them because I'm a short [ __ ]
but like when we were way over on the
other side of the store I looked over
and said oh there's all the Halloween
stuff like way up on the [ __ ] top
shelf that you need like the ladder to
get to but there was Christmas [ __ ]
everywhere they got like Christmas trees
they got like all the little wire
snowmans and all that kind of [ __ ] and
I'm just like are you guys like skipping
Halloween or what the [ __ ] is the deal
with that because Halloween is clearly
better
but yeah I like Christmas too I'm not
[ __ ] on Christmas their Christmas
trees are really expensive and we were
thinking oh [ __ ] we probably need to get
another Christmas tree
because our old Christmas tree oh
Christmas tree is too tall for the
ceiling
because where we put it in the old house
had like a higher ceiling than where we
put it in this house and it doesn't fit
yeah we don't have tall ceilings in it
well our tall ceilings are in a bedroom
so we're not gonna put it in there yeah
so yeah that would be weird I mean it
would be weird but I'm just saying it's
not no that'd be weird it's not usually
what's done
yeah I don't think it would be weird if
you had one in the living room and in
the bedroom like if because you really
liked Christmas and you're like oh I
want to wake up and see a Christmas tree
that's not weird but having one just in
the bedroom and not in the living room
that is a little bit weird although you
know you do you but yeah they're I kind
of feel like maybe though if we have to
order another Christmas tree I mean we
don't have to I'm just saying let's put
it on the card just that's true but
they're so God they're so expensive I
didn't realize yeah
even like the little dinky one was like
[ __ ] 200 no it wasn't that much they
weren't that expensive before it's
because of inflation I think inflation
you could probably honestly you could
probably find a cheaper one online than
you can at waves I would imagine
inflation and scarcity man prices are
going up
and I mean the ones that are pre-wired
with lights are like [ __ ] 300 I'm
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
go get a real [ __ ] Christmas tree and
sell them on the side of the road
they're they're expensive though too
we could just go sneak out in the woods
and cut one down
if nobody's looking you could probably
get away with that out here nobody see
you you gotta you gotta know where to go
although you kind of you may be risk
getting shot just get off my land you
know what I mean I wouldn't I'm like I
don't want a Christmas tree that bad
honestly I'll just make a paper one and
hang it on the wall you know if I'm
gonna get that if I can uh Zach says I
think I asked before Jenny but what's
your favorite era for graphic art I
think you did ask me but
um art nouveau
I'm really into Art Nouveau my whole
bathroom looks like that also really
like I really like
um Soviet era propaganda posters I
really like kind of the Bold design [ __ ]
that they had that that they had then I
really like that too but probably art
nubo is my favorite I don't know like I
like a lot a lot of different stuff I
like and I like really kind of um real
Baroque kind of like Victorian type of
[ __ ] too but probably Art Nouveau is my
favorite
uh Kalyn said what's a movie that you
and Tom watch every Christmas
Christmas Chronicles yeah with Kurt
Russell yeah
um I watch all of the Christmas mst3k
episodes pretty much every year which is
that would be uh Santa Claus conquerors
the Martians that was the Joel era one
then you got Santa Claus like the
Mexican one with the devil in it uh
that's the Mike era one and then they
did like on the newer show that they did
on Netflix with Jonah Ray they did the
Christmas that almost wasn't so I
usually watch those and honestly like
even on 2B and stuff like that they have
a whole bunch of Rift tracks Live Like
Christmas movies and Christmas shorts
like Santa and the ice cream Bunny and
all the kind of classic bad Christmas
movies and they have one that's like two
hours that's all like Christmas shorts
and that's pretty fun too that has like
what's that one about the [ __ ] sad
little Christmas tree
that's like it's live action it's a
short what the [ __ ] all I remember from
it is like the the Christmas tree keeps
it's from the point of view of the
Christmas tree like he can talk well he
can't talk but it's like a voiceover and
he keeps saying that he's small and of
no account and I'm just kind of like all
right it's super weird it's really weird
I don't know I don't know but uh yeah
some of this so that's what we watch but
I don't know I can't think of anything
else for sure we watch all the MST
episodes and for sure we watch Christmas
Chronicles sometimes we watch Christmas
Chronicles too but I don't like that but
as much but we always watch the first
one and usually I try to watch the
original Grange like with Boris Karloff
and original peanuts too but not I don't
always get around to that one and I like
the Rankin bass
um
Rudolph also so I sometimes I try to
watch that
John Smith said I'd get a Christmas tree
made of tinsel as the baby Jesus
suggested
I just I'm not sure if it's tacky or not
but I kind of like the white ones
you know what I mean
um because I figure if you're gonna have
a Christmas tree like the green ones are
nice I'm not saying that but honestly
I'm just kind of like I'm kind of tacky
like that so I'm just kind of like well
I'm gonna get a fake Christmas tree I
want the [ __ ] to look like really fake
I want one that's like white or like hot
pink or some [ __ ] like that
um you know what I mean actually kind of
you know it'd be cool if you had like a
hot pink Christmas tree with all black
ornaments on it I think that could look
kind of red but yeah like when I was
growing up
um yeah that's the apple pie yeah this
is the apple pie when this one's a lot
stronger you know what though that's a
different brand than the one we got
before that's old smokey like that one
the one we had before was what was it
called midnight moon or something yeah
that's right because that one had like a
much plainer like a white like a
minimalistically as strong as the other
one oh man it smells good I mean like I
said how can that be bad it can't be bad
it would be impossible for that to be
bad well that's what we said we picked
up because I was like well [ __ ] that
butter pecan lives to 19 Bros like
there's no way that that could be what
proof is that
there's no way that that can be bad
um
uh that's a that's a really good
question that you that you asked there
um it tastes stronger
that also says 35 No 70 proof so okay so
it's twice as strong as yeah
here you wanna try us now yeah 35
alcohol by volume it's good
it smells really good too
yeah it's good kind of like Dutch apple
pie with the with the crumble and the
crumble and the brown sugar on top of it
man that's good you can taste a little
bit of gram in it like yeah like crust
or something
Tammy says uh more heat to it sugar
lands is a good brand for moonshine I
don't think they had that there they had
that brand which is whatever what did I
say old smokey then they had the other
brand which I think is called Midnight
Moon they have kind of like a white
minimalist kind of thing and then they
had one more which was called ghost town
ghost something ghost something I think
midnight moon was about that same
strength yeah that's not about like that
I think huh that tastes that has like
that it's a really nice flavor like it's
really strong like at first but then
like after afterward it tastes like you
just had like a piece of really nice
apples it's got more cinnamon in it got
more of a cinnamon flavor than the other
one
um it's drier
it tastes a little stronger
oh boy is I saying oh I was saying when
I was growing up
um for a long time like we had a green
Christmas tree and then at my grandma's
house and then her green Christmas tree
got worn out and I was like please can
we get a white one please can we get
away when I was like I know it's tacky
but come on and she was like okay we can
get a white one so we got a white one
and so every year I would put up the
white one and we would either do a white
tree with all red ornaments and stuff on
it or a white tree with blue and green
ornaments which was my favorite so we
only had like blue and green lights but
it was white and it was so so pretty I
thought it was like really pretty
they're talking about Muppet Christmas
Carol oh that's good too and you know
what I think I watched
I think I watched them up at Christmas
Carol last year now that I think about
it I don't watch it every year but I
think I watched it last year and yes it
is awesome
uh Zach says here's a Christmas joke for
you I got a chocolate lab for Christmas
problem is it melted by mid-morning
[Laughter]
[Music]
Zach said I just found a tree just like
that I sent it to Tom's Facebook the
what tree a tree like a Christmas tree
we're talking about Christmas okay
uh
let's see John Smith said I only noticed
recently one of the shops in the
background of uh Muppet Christmas Carol
is Michael Kane's birth name Michael
whites that's right yeah what was his
first name Maurice right Maurice or
Morris Michael White that was a good
drama
Michael Kane his first name is Morris
yeah his real name was I think it was
Maurice Mickle white right I don't know
I would never remember that I'm pretty
sure that's a weird [ __ ] name
[Laughter]
did you want to go through the uh the
presents yeah well Sophie gave her so
Sophie sent her some uh three boxes with
a bunch of birthday gifts I can't
believe yeah she sent her a bunch of
stuff that she sent me like two boxes I
actually Consolidated them she takes
care of her sister wife
is that what I don't know really no
where did that come from I don't know it
just sounded cool it just sounded cool
yeah sure all right
oh Camp guy said those pre-wired trees
will eventually have lights burn out see
that's what I always thought of it's
like yeah it seems cool like for a year
or two until the lights go out and then
you're like well I gotta buy new ones to
put on there anyway so you know I get it
so here's the thing this is going to be
kind of difficult because there's like a
bunch of stuff in here
um so let me show like some of the big
stuff yeah just show the big stuff
and look like she sent me all these but
I don't I mean I was like Jesus Christ
girl I don't think she like she bought
me all this stuff because I was like oh
my God I think some of it she did some
of it oh thank you Victor thank you
there's a happy birthday happy birthday
thank you like I said it's early nobody
I'm not like trying to get I'm not
trying to get like special treatment
because she is my okay okay no I'm just
saying my actual birthday is Monday just
full disclosure but um you know but
that'll be a haunting show this is the
side this is the Side Tracks the
birthday Side Tracks look she sent me
The Creep Show
like thing from the movie which like I
said I was gonna make a version of it
yeah I was in FYE and they had this and
I really and I wanted it and I was just
like well I really want it but I
couldn't like afford it it was I was
like that's kind of too expensive so I
think it's like 30 bucks or something
like that but I really really wanted it
but yeah so that's really awesome and I
got that and then you might have to like
hold some stuff or put some stuff in the
holding area over there and then she
sent me this book she's like oh I don't
know if you have this and I'm like uh I
do not and I didn't even know it existed
because I do have a lot of books about
goth but I don't have this one uh art of
Gothic
so that's really cool yeah like it's all
yeah see it's all kind of like posters
yeah like it's all like this little
cyber business going on there I remember
that look yeah still around here it is
still around every now and then you see
it that looks like some Alien Sex Fiend
kind of [ __ ] going on there that's
pretty cool psychedelic Proto goth so
yeah this is like this is super cool
there's uh Susie there's a little Suzy
yeah
a dark Japanese thing yeah this book is
like really really cool yeah
and then there's this there's a lot of
stuff so you're gonna read this is like
an unboxing show it's so exciting yeah
and then look there's just kind of like
an anatomical
kind of thing the skeleton there with
all the notes which I love because I
love this kind of stuff I love this kind
of stuff that's like super super cool
okay this we gotta figure out a place to
put this where we can see it on the show
because I just got this today because
she sent three boxes and I got two of
them yesterday and then like this one
just showed up today look at this
Dracula's bed and breakfast and it's a
light up it lights up sign yeah I was
like we gotta put that back there
someplace yeah I mean maybe power right
there yeah I can like yeah I can put it
someplace like you can either hang it
with that
or take some strings or something yeah
and hang up to something but yeah that's
like that's really cool you really want
to see that anyway because of the Black
Walls yeah okay we'll see that's why
that's why I kind of did that kind of
situation hold on plug that in let me
see what that looks like yeah let's see
what it looks like
so this is actually good because I'm
drinking this kind of slow
you've already moved you've already
moved on to apple pie oh look at that
nice
yeah it's like it's kind of gold you
can't really see because it looks kind
of white on the thing but it's like
yellow and it's also bright that it
won't white out I don't think
yeah that looks really nice we're gonna
have to put that back there somewhere
because there's all kind of plugs and
[ __ ] like that back there because we're
definitely gonna have to hang that I
think I can see a place where I can put
it actually
I might have to take one I might have to
take that I might move that little David
J picture
that I know you can't even tell it's
David J from here but it is like it's
signed and I might take that down and
hang it in that space But hold on let me
uh drink
you can talk
look at this
it's a tiny tiny
Elvira yeah would like big thank you
Jeffy thank you Jeffy all right look at
her little boobies
and like hello and her baby it looks
like you Jeb
well they're little like because she's
little okay
[Laughter]
you know
some of the stuff I was like I kept on
the wraps because I didn't want Pookie
like climbing around in here and like
breaking [ __ ] you know what I mean yeah
because you know she's like oh a box I'm
gonna get in that [ __ ]
here's like a little Edward Scissorhands
Movie Maniacs little thing look at that
frame that's like
so okay
I'll put that up there man she got like
all kinds where did she got all this
stuff and look look
that's the backdrop and that's the
figure I'll have to put him over there
with my Headless Horseman yeah whose
head I actually lost
I lost this way actually I thought we
found a hit I think I lost both of his
heads because he had a Christopher
Walken head and he had a skull head
I found the heads that he that he cut
off like the severed head yeah I found
that but we thought it was a cat turd
we're like what the [ __ ] is that
I think I told them that's a [ __ ]
head
well yeah it just it fell off the floor
because it fell out of the figure's hand
yeah and like I just came in and it was
kind of dark in here I'm like oh my God
is that a [ __ ] cat turd on my floor
what is that and I was like scared to
touch it
but then it turned out it was just like
two little severed heads I was like oh
okay it's the Headless Horseman's heads
I get it
so there's that look at the little
earrings that's my favorite part like
they're little devil little Smiley devil
heads going here
so put some put stuff over there like
and then
this like I said some of the stuff is
still kind of like oh this is cool too
yeah like what is that a little Chinese
figure
oh okay yeah yeah it's like a Day of the
Dead yeah he's like 10 yeah metal
there's that
and let's see
like I said some of the stuff I haven't
even like really looked at all that
close yet because I've just
and then
little guy
oh his face almost kind of looks like a
sea stack
like he has like sleece back guys let me
see what I see what I'm saying
he can sit on there look at his little
bony butt
you can sit back there with the other
little
homes
and then oh this is cool too
okay this is like
that's like a sticker I think it's a
sticker from the lore podcast which is
awesome
and then this is like a coaster little
thing tile situation with HP Lovecraft
on it
that's a great quote actually
okay put that over there
and then let's see what else
I just can't I can't believe like all
the stuff that's in here I was just like
I opened it and I was like what the [ __ ]
lips oh my God a little flask yeah
that's cool check that out
I love that kind of [ __ ] too
I think it says Fright Night on it
oh and here this made me laugh too
um Spooky's looking in the Box what the
[ __ ] is it that's what I mean it's for
me yeah this is called mommy knows worst
highlights from the Golden Age of bad
parenting advice which
I'm totally gonna get into this I have
one called
um what the hell is it called it's
something about like the weird like
mackerel diet plan or something like
that it's all about like the weird
[ __ ] diet fads of the 1970s with all
those like [ __ ] weird cards on them
and stuff and it's [ __ ] hilarious
and let's see
then we got this this is also very cool
little wall hanging there
says spooky on it
with little skulls
and
okay these are like framed
postcards like big frame to those cards
look at that
cool all this [ __ ] is
how'd she get so much cool [ __ ]
and like why did she like extend it's
like you know
if I had all this cool [ __ ] I would keep
it
oh and she also sent me like some some
good like fake nails and stuff gel
fantasy oh look at those they're kind of
like oh
and some blue and whatnot
and then here's this little guy
with his little
arms and legs
oh [ __ ] I almost did it I was so [ __ ]
clutzy I just can't [ __ ] drink it I'm
not it's like look that's all I drank
okay like I literally have it's not I'm
just klutzy even when I'm sober
that like frighten it with the pumpkin
shape
so cool it's just like so cool I love it
look at this this is hilarious because
this is a plastic Easter egg that she
said was it her her sister Drew Nick
Cave's face on it
as one does and I was like wow that's
that's actually a pretty good uh pretty
good like this there
Little Nicky bag
yeah too yeah it's like that's what I
thought I was like that's him all right
that's him all right okay is there
anything out here yeah yeah yeah
and okay this is all puffy there's just
more fingernails in there and then oh
and then there's like a little sticker
like that
and then
this is I think that's glue for the nail
okay we're getting down stickers and
glue that's the nail glue all right now
let me see because I think
let me check and make sure because
there's I think there's other stuff in
here
at the end of it like I said it's really
exciting it's like an um
a combine show
and then oh yeah this is cool too okay
this was just in the box that came today
look at this
look at
it he look at his little face what is
that it's a little devil oh okay he's a
little devil look at his little tail oh
my God I love it
I love it all right
okay is that oh
okay let me make sure everything's out
oh now I gotta save that for last
because that's like super funny and then
we have like two of these little
werewolfies
so they can fight
there's that and then look at this you
guys
look at little Jaws
little jaws and he has the little thing
in his mouth that's gonna make it blow
up smile is that a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right is that it
is that it I think it's it she put a she
put lists in here look how look how
conscientious she is she's got a whole
list she put lists like that you want to
make sure that everything came okay and
wasn't broken
she's got a manifest yeah it's a
manifest okay I think that's it I think
that's it but yeah oh my God Sophie yeah
you are the coolest
always and forever like I love every
single thing that's in there does that's
like the coolest [ __ ] ever coolest [ __ ]
ever
I haven't even like okay
now pokey's back there going you guys
done playing yeah what about you poke
she's laying on her back [ __ ]
fighting stuff murder Hornet said whose
birthday well my birthday is Monday
Monday
come here poke
tell tell them about uh Pookie's little
oh there's actually there's actually two
things about Pokey because there's you
know the dream and then there's yeah and
then there's the the other thing I fell
asleep in the man cave in there
uh with my head a little headphone on
and I woke up because I heard Boo Boo
and in my in that in my room over there
I have one of my motorcycles
it's a mini bike that I built
it's got behind it it's got blue excuse
me green [ __ ] lights and [ __ ] [ __ ]
display piece like a display piece you
know it's it's it's like a an
award-winning [ __ ] Honda CT70 trail
bike that my dad had when he when I was
a little kid and he gave it to me and I
turned it into a cafe racer
that's a badass I could I could win a
I could win a motor scooter a mini bike
competition with that just just
and it just looks [ __ ] badass anyway
uh
Pookie likes to sleep underneath the
inside those blue lights or green lights
she loves it yeah she likes the lights
in here yeah so
oh wait she wakes me up I remember like
that and I looked back there and she's
underneath the motorcycle looking at me
like are you there and then I was what's
up I'm here you know and I said come
here and she [ __ ] runs towards me and
jumps up on top of the damn little
mattress that I have in there and gets
up up on top of my [ __ ] chest and
lays down [ __ ] looks all Meek I said
you had bad dream didn't you then she
that she did she had a bad dream yeah
I've heard her like sometimes like
she'll curl up in that chair back there
yeah and she'll fall asleep and I'll be
like working and I'll hear her all of a
sudden go yeah yeah
and like I turn around and I'm like oh
no she's having a bad dream and then
she'll wake up and go and I'm just like
you okay yeah she's like
she's laid on my chest without a little
bad dream five or ten minutes until say
Daddy Daddy yeah until she chilled out
oh then she climbed down next to me and
fell asleep poor baby
she also um
alerted us to uh to a bug today
oh yeah
yeah she was outside the door and her
going wow
and I was like what
and she was around the corner and as I
was going around the corner
I saw her looking up at the wall fate
but I couldn't see what she was looking
at until I go turn around and she's
[ __ ] looking at she yells at it
there's a dragonfly
so I hit the dragonfly and she's
catches it she's got it on the ground I
got it I got it I got it
oh my God
from her and [ __ ] if I could do it
outside and then she stayed there
looking for it yeah she doesn't
understand when you take it yeah and and
let it outside you know what I mean
she's like I got to stay here in this
area yeah it's here somewhere it's here
someplace yeah it's funny because she
used to do that sometimes because every
now and then when she used to go outside
at our old house she would sneak in a
lizard from outside to play with she'd
bring in a little Playmate and so
sometimes we would find like a little
terrified lizard like behind the thing
going [ __ ] help me help me and so then
but like she would because you knew that
there was a lizard in the house because
Pookie would be like go trying to get
underneath some [ __ ] and she'd be like
yeah and I'm like oh my God there's
something under there it's either the
bug or a lizard she could see you take
the lizard and put it outside and then
she'd go right back to where she last
Saw
she's like looking all over yeah
she didn't understand hands she doesn't
understand that well she doesn't have
she just has little boxes she can't
really pick she's [ __ ] funny man well
she can pick up she picks up her toys
and but in one little flaw so she can
kind of go like that scoop it yeah but
she can't really pick nothing up okay so
um I guess the uh
uh introduction or the beginning part of
the first part of the show is over
Zach says what was the obsession with
1970s home cooking and suspending
everything in jello oh she taught me the
aspect yeah well I kind of feel like
that's maybe what it was I know it seems
weird and it seemed weird to me too
until I looked into the history because
Jello was you know gelatin prior to
Jello coming out and being like instant
and everything
um anything that was a gelatin dish was
like really really uh labor intensive
yeah and pretty much only rich people
ate it like I said it was usually aspic
I feel like it was not I feel like prior
to aspect was usually not fruit flavors
right it was usually like tomato or meat
or something like that it was like made
with like meat jelly like I don't think
he actually I don't think he actually
I'd have to ask my mom
I don't think you actually ate aspic I
think they made those aspect as more of
display
and it'd be in the middle of the damn
thing [ __ ] floating in gelatin
ham pieces of ham cut out to be like
fish and [ __ ] dump asparagus to look
like trees and [ __ ] yeah I saw one like
that but somebody made that kind of for
a joke because it was in like an old
cookbook and they're like oh my I'm
gonna do this because it looked like
yeah it was like a Jello like aquarium
essentially so it was like this bluish
Jello that had kind of all these
vegetables and fruits in it that were
cut out to look like fish and [ __ ] like
that I don't think they actually ate it
I mean I would hope I think it was just
a display I think it was edible but I
don't think people ate it
maybe it was like an ice sculpture it
was like the ice sculpture yeah like
nobody's supposed to like eat that right
anything because I've I've seen modern
reviews where people will go through all
the problem of doing an aspect thing
then they eat it and they go like this
is terrible why would you eat this I
don't think they ate it why do you waste
so much time with this it's awful yeah
yeah that's the thing and honestly it's
just kind of like I mean jello's fine
um I don't think we ever I don't
remember if my grandma
or my mom ever made anything like that
like because I know there were some
things where you had a thing where you
put the jello like in a but it was like
a bundt cake pan yeah and then you'd put
usually it was pineapple I feel like
yeah that was usual which that's it's
not terrible no that's not that weird
but then that they would start
suspending like other things in there
like hot dogs and that was ass pick and
[ __ ] and I don't think they were
actually supposed to be eating that
yeah but the hot dogs thing I don't get
that no but that that generation would
eat raw hot dogs they're not really raw
but they've they're cooked but I did
when I was a kid too but I was stupid I
didn't know what I was doing
did he baloney and [ __ ] hot dogs and
baloney are like about the same I did
too when I was a kid I hate baloney I
hate it too but I ate it when I was a
kid yeah but it wasn't my again it's
like my favorite it's like something you
give to a kid yeah money's a lot better
if you fry it but well yeah but
anything's better if you cook it
Camp guy said I like strawberries and
Jello yeah see something like that would
be fine but I kind of feel like the
weird [ __ ] about it was that if you're
gonna do like an aspect type dish which
why would you but you know what I don't
know your life but um I feel like you
have to either choose let's go sweet or
let's go Savory I don't think that it
really works it's like hey let's suspend
like a bunch of savory stuff in like
strawberry jello that's that's gonna be
a bad time see y'all are [ __ ] me up
and she's [ __ ] me up this stuff
because it gets it out of order
what you find in those old recipe books
and then what your what Your Meemaw
would actually make for you when you
were at your Memaw's house it was very
different okay my grandmother made those
gelatin desserts they were [ __ ] good
they were really good and it was like
that butt cake another round cake with
the whole what the Bundt Cakes that you
call it bundt cake yeah like a bundt
cake yeah that's kind of it would be
like
it would be rigged up where you would
have the top half of when it was sitting
there it'd be orange the top half and
then the second half would be red yeah
yeah and in the orange half
she'd have a couple cans of those damn
mandarin orange slices in there okay and
then in the red part on the bottom you'd
have maraschino cherries and [ __ ] like
that yes it should be delicious put a
little bit of Cool Whip on that yeah
exactly and then it's a slice of it out
and you put whipped cream on it
and then there were some others then
there was some other stuff that she
would make she'd make a block of Jello
gelatin right a gelatin or some sort
some some type
take that and then kind of whip it and
mix it with Cool Whip
yeah yeah yeah so yeah my grandma used
to make that all the time that was
really good that was actually really
good and then it had fruit in it yeah
fresh fruit like diced up pieces of
apple or oranges and stuff usually
strawberries we made it with
strawberries and it was like a light
fluffy
um kind of like an Ambrosia type thing
it was it was really good so
the [ __ ] that they're always reviewing
and making crazy [ __ ] like aspic and
stuff
if you're picking the worst stuff I
think well yeah that's the fun of it
yeah that's not what well because yeah I
don't think people were necessarily
eating that like every day yeah but I
will say because you particularly those
Weight Watchers cards that came out in
the 70s because my mom had those
um some of the [ __ ] on there I'm not
like some of the stuff on there was fine
it was normal food but there were so
many in there that were like really
really weird yeah that people just got
[ __ ] tickled by the whole situation
and said we're gonna make some of this
and they were awful well I said maybe
that was what it was that's how they got
you to lose weight because it's like
here make all this food and then haha
it's terrible and you don't want to eat
it so lose weight Southern grandma
or black grandma have been the same okay
it's the same it's the same menu all
right black grandma and Southern Grandma
are the same grandma is just but uh
because they'll call it soul food up
north
but in the South it's just southern
foods that's what we all eat that
but
the the food that she would give you was
it was good it was good but it was the
idea for it was 60s era a lot of the
stuff that they're giving you or prior
to the 60s it might have been even more
traditional like peach cobbler
or peach cobbler with self-rising flour
is probably 60s
but they made that before self-rising
flour probably
uh things like fried okra that predates
1960s that's old [ __ ] so same thing with
like real cornbread which is like eating
[ __ ] hard tech
it's [ __ ] real coarse no sugar in it
at all that [ __ ] predates everything but
but what you mean ball is making for you
she thinks this [ __ ] space age is
[ __ ] like [ __ ] bright colored gelatin
that's Space Age [ __ ]
it came out of a package it didn't
require any Refrigeration it was kind of
instant and it was they loved that [ __ ]
and they could make stuff with it
but when it came to the gelatin I
remember the bundt cake type stuff
but I remember that being really good
but it was layered
they do it layer by layer let it
solidify and then [ __ ] put the next
[ __ ] fruit in there and then the next
thing and they'd do it so it was real
colorful and bright and you cut a slice
of it out and you put Cool Whip yeah or
you had that too yeah and then another
thing was is they would just take
gelatin and kind of blend it
with Cool Whip yeah and it would be this
nice
Airy creamy kind of a fruity
generic dessert you know
pieces of fruit in it it's kind of like
mousse yeah like a flip like a fruit
flavored mousse yeah and it had those
art those artificial colors that were
bright and Space Age and [ __ ] me and Mom
would be impressed with that [ __ ] back
in the 1960s and she's bringing it to
you in the 80s yeah well she's like a
little kid thank God that I don't have
to spend all [ __ ] day like cooking
now exactly I can just do this and it
looks nice and she's like so I get it
and she can get the egg beater and go
like that and turn it and turn this
thing into this wonderful 60s
you're nothing and then I put all the
tiki music and [ __ ] or whatever you know
what I mean [ __ ] you know
drinking [ __ ] drinking himself to
death by the time you were born that
kind of [ __ ] you know one thing that
generation was like that I remember like
particularly in jello I always feel like
um on Fourth of July or Memorial Day or
Labor Day or whatever they would always
do like the jello that was layered like
red white blue yeah like they had I feel
like everybody did that but they did it
like yeah and like they did it like in
little ice cream truck yeah it would
just be like the red Jello at the bottom
and then there'd be like a layer of Cool
Whip and then there'd be like a layer of
like blue flavor which I guess was
raspberry now that I'm thinking yeah I
don't really know I know those that were
supposed to be another one if you you're
Southern or your black grandma
would give you was key lime pie
and that [ __ ] was [ __ ] awesome just
condensed milk [ __ ] lime juice or
lemon juice graham cracker crust and
[ __ ] whipped cream on top yeah super
easy to make I liked lemon meringue
better but beautiful beautiful yeah and
then you had to damn lemon bundt cake
with the [ __ ] lemon icing on the top
of it easy to make fantastic
Southern Classic
[ __ ] just
cobbler of all kinds which is just you
can whip that up in no time out of
nothing well that shit's like super easy
super easy but if you just basically
dump it in a casserole dishes sticks of
butter
I mean it's just yeah yeah they all die
to diabetes and [ __ ] cholesterol but
they didn't know any better
and they probably like enjoyed it they
went out happy yeah fat little [ __ ]
John Smith said when I was a kid it was
an eye-opener if I had a friend over to
encounter my mother's [ __ ] up Albanian
dishes I don't like Albanian okay
there is some good Slavic food man
borscht is [ __ ] great up up in
Michigan they eat pierogies which are
like oh my God I love her pierogies are
really good they're like a little like a
little wonton
with mashed potatoes or or [ __ ]
onions in it and mashed potatoes with
cheese and then you dip them in sour
cream [ __ ] super good yeah I love
protein um they sell those everywhere
now though we're not even really liking
it but there's there's a lot of goods
somebody made some on MasterChef the
other day as a matter of fact a lot of
good Slavic Foods out there you just
gotta know what to make
I mean there's good food everywhere yeah
to be honest
you know Camp guy said you can still buy
uh lime pies at Dollar General Edwards
Pie Company
Victor says key lime pie made me gay
yeah
all right Make You Queer as [ __ ]
ing every time I'd [ __ ] see it I feel
that gay gravitation and [ __ ]
snap out of that [ __ ] man my [ __ ] my
internal Mass was too great I was able
to resist it it's a terrible death yeah
Eternal man it's too great oh my God
yeah
let me see
um hold on
if y'all have never had key lime pie go
ahead and get me [ __ ] 20 push-ups and
punish yourself
key lime pie like I said easy to make
it's in the cookbook we sell
yeah I like it yeah in the southern
section and I like key lime pie but I
prefer lemon meringue gonna say lemon
meringue is good but [ __ ] lemon meringue
it's it's harder to make well it is I've
made it before it is harder making
meringue is is a [ __ ] it is yeah
um uh key lime is something you can make
just in under an hour in your [ __ ]
kitchen at home no matter where you are
in the world if you're in England you
can get the [ __ ] to make key lime pie
all you need is condensed milk that's
the that's the hardest thing to get
and graham crackers and lime juice lime
juice easy it doesn't even have to be
lime it could be lemon juice and then
just add a little bit of green food yeah
that works too it doesn't tastes pretty
much the same
[Laughter]
and then you can use your own whipped
cream or make homemade whipped cream or
Cool Whip I don't like cool whip on it I
like real whipped cream on it Cool Whip
has its own thing whip is Cool Whip it's
its own animal
Cool Whip is good blended in with
[ __ ] Jello it is yeah because I think
they're about if you're gonna go Whole
Hog with like the right the pre-made and
like I said I'm not [ __ ] on that
because
you can use some of those ingredients
and like doctor them up and like make
some really good [ __ ] with that like you
know if you don't have a lot of money
Zach is talking about uh his grandma
used making pineapple fluffy flammable
fluffy I probably know that under
another name which one is pineapple
fluffy explain it that does sound
familiar I probably have had it but I
don't know I don't know yeah because
there's differences in Regional names
because you know like ambrosia salad
right yeah is that the same thing as
Waldorf salad uh no but similar it's a
similar concept and then another one
that is just a damn southern classic and
it's probably outside the South too it's
[ __ ] pineapple upside down cake yeah
I can [ __ ] make a badass pineapple
anybody can really that's an easy one
pineapple upside down is [ __ ] great
and it's made out of just [ __ ] you
could get out of any store the corner
store back in the 1960s you could get
everything to make
my favorite when I was growing up was uh
gooey butter cake that's good too which
is also easy to make always and you
basically you make it with boxed cake
mixes yeah like a couple different box
cakes making just a whole bunch of
butter and like some other stuff in
there it's like really really good
uh Camp guy said my mother made a
layered jello with a layer of sour cream
between two sheets of jello I've never
heard where the strawberries came in
yeah I might be all right though because
you got that cool creamy heavy yeah
depending on how thick that layer is
kind of feel like maybe cream cheese
would be better yeah well what you could
do is you could use you could use sour
cream and add sugar to that sour cream
to sweeten it slightly
and blend it together and let it sit
that would probably be really good if
not
cream cheese and sugar a little layer of
that yeah I feel like that would
probably be better yeah like I'm not
[ __ ] on sour cream because sour
cream is really good I mean cream
cheeses I have to have it and see what
it is there was [ __ ] that we used to do
even back in the 80s
that sound is [ __ ] crazy and it was
crazy but it was good you
made out of Common Ground one of the
things that we they used to be
everywhere were canned Pairs and it
would be pair halves they were giving
them away
so you take out a can a pair of halves
and put the pear half down and put a
dollop of [ __ ] mayonnaise in the
center of it and and grated cheese
usually like American cheese I feel like
was usually it was supposed to be
cheddar I know and uh and then I always
thought it was yeah American cheese and
you just eat with it eat it with a spoon
and yeah my mommy so like I said when
she was on Weight Watchers she would eat
this it sounds crazy
when I first saw it I'm like man that's
crazy
but then I ate some of it and I was like
that's pretty good though there's
something about the sweetness with the
creaminess with that slight tart in the
Mayo and then that pungent part of the
[ __ ] cheddar cheese and the saltiness
of that cheese it kind of went together
I remember sprinkling a little bit of
salt on it but there's there's a reason
that people sometimes often eat apple
pie with a slice of cheddar yeah you
know what I mean those two flavors
actually do go really well together it
sounds it sounds weird but they actually
do go well together so I can see where
they're coming from with that because I
feel like that was a very popular Weight
Watchers thing where you either had it
was either a pear half with it was
either cottage cheese or sometimes
American cheese
um and sometimes it was on a bed of
lettuce yeah you had that going on too
yeah now that you said that we always
had it with
mayo and and
um mayo and cheddar cheese but if it was
cottage cheese and cheddar cheese that'd
probably be even better yeah I would
think that probably even better
and it was grated uh cheddar cheese on
top of it
yeah so like I said it's not it sounds
weird but it's not that weird because
people eat apple pie all the time like
that's a pretty common thing but Mayo
you would think that's not so much fun
Mayo why the [ __ ] Mayo but that's that
was a some 60s [ __ ] and I'd see it
as a kid in diners and people would hand
it out
and you'd be like oh that yeah okay
and then you take a bite of it and go
yeah it's pretty good there's just
something about it
I don't know they were making things up
out of what they had sure some Chef made
that [ __ ] up
probably came out and you would not
got that [ __ ] from Reader's Digest a lot
of that I'm sure a lot of that [ __ ]
there's this magazine that used to
happen in in the United States before
the internet it was Reader's Digest
stupid little [ __ ] books
it's kind of almost like a TV Guide but
it had all this
literature in it and recipes
it didn't even have current events
but women would subscribe to it it's
mostly women thing
but a lot of recipes came out of
Reader's Digest surprise me if they
[ __ ] that was something out of
Reader's Digest Readers Digest I feel
like that wasn't really a recipe thing
like if you were gonna get recipes it
was usually Church cookbooks or
something like Good Housekeeping or red
book or something like that like a
regular Writer's Digest had recipes in
it they might have but I don't really
remember because my grandmother had a
bunch of those yeah and I kind of feel
like Reader's Digest was more articles
like funny like joke you might say
columns there might have been an
association that maybe the woman that
was I probably just remember the same
women that had Readers Digest or also
had a bunch of recipes so it might have
been maybe I'm just I'm thinking I was a
little kid yeah I'm thinking like
recipes back in the back in the day
probably came from like church cookbooks
because there's a lot of those and some
people nowadays like that are into like
retro kind of cooking like collect those
because each Church would put out their
own like they'd ask all the church
ladies hey give us all your recipes and
they put them to like compile them like
for charity or whatever so there's a lot
of those like floating around still but
I kind of feel like in even nowadays
because they still do have these mags
like red book and Good Housekeeping and
stuff like that those are all still
around
yeah yeah so and their whole thing is
like I feel like I don't know I don't
read them but it's like half of them
just looking for the articles on the
cover like in the checkout line at the
grocery store it seems like half of the
[ __ ] is look at these decadent desserts
you can make and the other half of it is
like lose weight you fat [ __ ] you know
what I mean so it's just kind of like
mixed signals is what I'm saying they're
giving you a mixing downstairs I have
cookbook falling apart it's been in the
family forever it's it's from the 1930s
is it from the 30s for I think it's from
the third I can't remember I looked it
up one time but yeah I got it down there
because we had one and I can barely hold
it together it's a Duncan Hines cookbook
and it has some of the best recipes it's
got the best chocolate eclair recipe
you'll ever [ __ ] and I made them
chocolate eclairs [ __ ] made a video
Jenny had some of those things the
[ __ ] will make you fat
beautiful chocolate giant and they were
really really good too how to make the
custard how to make the [ __ ]
chocolate on top
how to make the eclair but that rest
that that recipe book what is so cool
about that recipe book is it came out in
a time when when the United States had
no Supply chains
and no knowledge of anything very exotic
everything was made by hand
okay
all of your ingredients were made by
hand another there are whole sections in
there on how to make condiments like how
to make mayonnaise
how to make mustard
how to make ketchup how to make relish
how to cook all different kinds of meats
it's not
it's all very basic and then there's
whole baking sections how to make breads
different kinds of breads the rules
behind making breads all the different
kind of Wheats that you need or not
Wheats all different kind of flowers you
need
the differences between them
and this is these were made for teenage
girls really that's the book was made
for teenage girls I was going to say
they probably got them as wedding
presents yeah like here cook some [ __ ]
for your new husband uh no figure it out
before well yeah you'd have to know like
home ec yeah homak high school girls
and they knew their [ __ ] man they could
make anything
they could make the components and
that's really the key
if you're in if you really want to know
and then there's a bunch of substitution
stuffs like how to make sour cream
that's some fun you know that's wild
nowadays you have the internet you could
look that up
but before the internet that book was
[ __ ]
where this weight in gold well yeah it's
like the Bible it was like the Bible
yeah that's why I was still it's still
in I still have it
you know
I mean that kind of stuff is like really
interesting to me because yeah like I
said it's it's easy nowadays to just
look up whatever the [ __ ] you want it's
like hey look I have these random
ingredients in my house and you can find
like 40 bajillion recipes like how to
make something out how do I make
prepared mustard
you know it'd be like that well that
book will tell you like how to start
with [ __ ] mustard roots or powdered
mustard and then how to make a prepared
mustard out of that
that's pretty wild
how to make mayo now you don't you're
gonna learn that in culinary school
anyway mayonnaise is not hard to to make
I used to make it one of the restaurants
used to work at it's just it's boiled
hard-boiled egg whites and vinegar
mostly you just got to whip it together
right I forgot what else is in it but
the average person doesn't know how to
make mayo if you guys if you got a
[ __ ] supply of eggs you can make all
the Mayo you want
unfortunately this housing commission
we're in now they don't let you have any
chickens
unless you keep them inside the house
yeah
says you could have six hands
you know that that's anywhere you have
six heads
but I think you know your local Housing
Commission said no you can't have that
[ __ ] around here things run around
everywhere
but yeah they like to wander yeah you
gotta let them out to feed yeah if you
have six hands
you got a steady supply of eggs you'll
never really have to buy eggs they're
just constantly laying I remember uh Dr
Matt he must have had [ __ ] a dozen
hands and there were more eggs than
[ __ ] 10 people could eat they just
they just [ __ ] lay eggs like [ __ ]
crazy
that's all they did was lay around
[ __ ] egg lay eggs Camp guys said two
things my old man used to make three
bean salad and cornbread with buttermilk
on Sunday evenings I wish I had his
three bean salad recipe yeah three bean
salad's pretty good
then Zach said my Grandma had an orgy
Brown lava lamp in her house probably
from the 70s and I was so mesmerized by
it as a kid yeah
um in my grandma's house she had like a
red one and I actually inherited it
later like so I got it for a while and
it was like the one of the old like
super heavy ones
I used to love that thing I thought it
was like and it lasted like forever I
don't know what happened to it but
I think it broke eventually but
let's see somebody said does anyone else
having connection problems I don't think
so everything's going good here
Zach says as disgusting as they sound
there's some Norwegian dishes I'd like
to try someday
a dig man
Norwegian food
never had any spices it's mostly about
fish preservation
and that's just nasty okay uh
all that Nordic food you know what I
mean
the best food that you're gonna find in
those places is foreign
they don't have spices it's not and the
thing is is that I think I think their
diet's been pretty much [ __ ] updated
they're not eating everything that they
used to eat there wasn't much there
too cold you know
well the thing about it is that like I
said since the Advent of the internet
like I kind of feel like everybody's
just eating whatever I don't even know
if there's yeah there's still like local
stuff but I think it's like less
pronounced than it used to be
John Smith said I grew up in Newcastle
my mother's baklava may have been from
Mars it was so exotic baklava you know
what's weird it's like I didn't I didn't
actually used to like baklava but I kind
of like developed a taste for it after a
while picture says coconut cream pie
that is also very good I'm kind of like
a little bit behind
it's a food show it's always a food show
I mean you know
[Laughter]
yeah talking about Waldorf salad yeah I
think that when we were growing up it's
essentially the same thing it's got like
shredded coconut Mandarin oranges mini
marshmallows that kind of stuff we just
called that usually Waldorf salad but
I've seen it called Ambrosia I've seen
it called other things too and some
people I think because um somebody was
saying about Pistachio Pistachio being
in it yeah because I kind of feel like
there's some sometimes like the whipped
cream [ __ ] is like green
foreign
there's a bunch of stuff like that those
creamy desserts with all the stuff yeah
and it's a weird mixture of
sweet and savory happening in it
with crunchy stuff inside of a light
creamy
this stuff's good it is very good it's
like way stronger than the other drink
though yeah that's real drink there so
I'm gonna have to like sip it yeah that
last one was like that's like a candy
drink that's the real thing right there
yeah
man it's delicious too it's like uh
Gatlinburg Tennessee it's from Tennessee
Gatlinburg Tennessee that's what it says
it's like uh
on top by the day Dave Parker's in there
what's up okay so I'm way behind because
yeah we haven't been we haven't been and
we haven't been to mannequins in a while
we need to [ __ ] go back and
mannequins it looks like it's been
blasting lately
they're having like they got all kind of
blow up sex dolls and they're kind of
having all kind of actually I saw a
video from there earlier today that had
an almost naked dude dancing on the bar
so I was like oh that looked like a fun
night yeah I think it was a candy though
he was just wearing a jock strap yeah
well you get drunk the girls were
[ __ ] will you get drunk enough you'd
totally [ __ ] get it yeah I just
[ __ ] pulled it I got my boots on and
[ __ ] like that like we're like that I
can see you doing that
I've seen you get on stripper poles and
stuff like that before yeah
um
Yukon Cornelius 81 said my grandmother
had one a recipe called Chinese pudding
it was just shepherd's pie with creamed
corn in it
how was that Jenny tell your grandma go
ahead
because that's shepherd's pie with corn
with corn that's and you and I see it
there's nothing there's nothing Chinese
the Chinese don't even have corn
I mean
that's really weird and I kind of feel
like they put core because I remember I
said before that when I was in the UK
one of the weirdest things and now that
I think it's not that weird but it's
like I was weirded out by it like in the
90s that they had frozen pizzas that had
like you had like all the normal flavors
like cheese and pepperoni like that but
then they had one that had like corn
niblets on it yeah corn does not belong
on Pizza I know the European's gonna get
mad
Japanese gonna get mad but the Japanese
would put octopus ink on Pizza that
doesn't belong there either we're gonna
get the Italian mob together to try to
stop this [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] dishonor
against Italian technology
Pizza is not really Italian okay it's
Italian-American
because Pizza back in Italy was more
like Focaccia it's not really Pizza
came from the early 1900s and that's
Italian Americans
living the good life
in Chicago and New York
they now have access to more ingredients
and more money than what they had back
in the old country
so they're going overboard with pizza
and that's the pizza you know of you had
the Chicago deep dish you had [ __ ]
Pizza Pie you had New York Pizza none of
that existed back in Italy okay this is
the [ __ ] they have pimped it out to the
max
and and we have to [ __ ] give credit
where credit is due
Italian mafia really helped make pizza
famous okay because
the newspapers would focus on guys
gangsters saying that yeah they're
hanging out in these strange places
where they serve this weird Italian dish
called Pizza yeah and that's how that
[ __ ] which is hilarious that was like a
century ago yeah it's hardly any time at
all like the pizza was like really
really exotic yeah which is super funny
to me yeah
but yeah that's like yeah but Big Al Big
Al made Pete help make pizza famous and
it was Chicago pizza and then there were
the Italian American Italian American
Pizza Wars they go on to this day
each little Italian American Clans gonna
[ __ ] say their pizza's the best
Chicago Pizza
New York Pizza people forget about
Detroit Pizza it's [ __ ] square it's
all good and it's in a metal pan I'll
eat any of it not gonna lie but the
pizza that went around the world and
marched around the world and conquered
it and ended up in other countries is
not Italian pizza it is an evolution of
the American Pizza
it was Italian
but it was an Italian-American it was
Italians in America doing that I do kind
of feel like most people globally at
least from what I could determine do
kind of see Pizza as an American yeah
food yeah an Italian-American which
technically yes it was immigrants that
started it but
the way they like you said the way they
pimped it out I think that kind of made
it a more right they kind of went
somewhere back in Italy pizza was junk
food that was something you sold on the
street
it was more like Focaccia there wasn't
much on it which is also good it was
good too but it was just something
[ __ ] not like you'd see like right
nowadays you have these guys here in in
the United States now from in these
Italian families and they're
they know about pizza but they're going
to do it right yeah let's just put more
on it let's let's [ __ ] put this [ __ ]
on roids let's maximize this this turn
pizza from a street food to a [ __ ]
meal all right and that's what they did
and that's the pizza that conquered the
world
even in Brazil
which has a lot of Italian
influence in Brazil when I'm you know
and I live there okay
even even the pizza they had there was
aping Chicago Pizza
that's what that's that's what they were
trying to emulate
and it was
not even close
the temperatures weren't high enough it
wasn't crispy enough
the spicing was wrong
and it wasn't that good and they didn't
like it even the Brazilians didn't even
like it it was almost like it was
steamed
the best pizzerias in
Sao Paulo Brazil when I lived there and
some of them did appear right before I
left
we're copying American recipes Italian
American recipes and those were [ __ ]
kicking ass
if they were along the lines of New York
or Chicago Pizza New York or Chicago
deep dish if they went along those lines
they succeeded anything outside that
doesn't succeed
because people have the same taste buds
you know people know what's good
yeah mostly yeah there are some
variations but most of the time yeah
yeah
Panther says Reader's Digest puns and
jokes trait homilies vapid inspirational
stories yeah I remember those and word
power quiz quizzes Good Times yeah see I
always kind of figured I do I do think
they had recipes in there sometimes but
I don't think that was their main thing
okay their main things I've seen one
yeah because like I said my grandma
always had like a bunch and sometimes I
would read them because my grandpa read
them and stuff as well but I kind of
feel like it was more yeah like just
[ __ ] like articles and little jokes
and [ __ ] like that yeah uh Yukon
Cornelius said a lot of the strange
recipes from the 50s and 60s came on the
back of food packaging I do kind of feel
like some of the weirdest recipes was
just kind of like a corporate office
being like hey we have this product like
Jello pudding or whatever the [ __ ] it
was like canned green beans for example
and they're like now we need to write a
cookbook
using this thing using this product and
some of the stuff
uh uh you know so they try to like fill
out a book essentially so they were like
they didn't even try any of this stuff
out I suspect although some stuff that
you think sounds weird because okay one
thing that went around for a while like
back in the day that I think a lot of
people were grossed out by but which is
actually delicious is putting ketchup in
a chocolate cake mix like a lot of
people thought that was super gross and
were like what the [ __ ] were you even
thinking are you high like when you came
up with that but if you actually do it
it's actually good it doesn't taste
anything like tomato or ketchup or
anything like that Oscar's [ __ ] us
and [ __ ] with us about being the Food
Network go ahead and [ __ ] check off
this is the way the car we didn't start
we didn't start out as we were talking
about food that's just yeah that's just
kind of happened
Victor says homemade bread sounds good
but ain't nobody got time for that I'm
not doing it every now and then well
yeah and we've been talking about making
some but honestly there's recipes out
there that are like for no knead Breads
and like all kind of stuff that's like
way easier like I saw something on some
channel the other day I can't remember
how she did it but she basically made
like kind of just like a loaf in her
Dutch oven and like I said you didn't
even have to knead it or anything and it
came out like and it looked really good
so you know and she's like yeah I make
these every now and then so I can make
sandwiches out of the [ __ ] Joshua says
yep in Naples Pizza is basically
Beggar's food yeah right
let's see
yeah Tammy said my gram has a chocolate
cake recipe that uses Mayo very very
moist yeah it's like it sounds weird at
first but it's not that weird well
honestly it's not that weird using Mayo
in the stuff because Mayo is basically
just oil and eggs right so it's just
kind of oil why not it's just the white
of a hard-boiled egg oil and I think it
has a little bit of vinegar in it been a
long time since I've made it
because you can make a pie crust with
just Mayo just mayo and and and flour
and flour you mix it together and
there's enough there and you can push it
out make a dough like that and then bake
it it's great bake it pre-bake it a
little bit
in your pan pull it back out put
whatever you're putting in it and then
put it back in
um but no uh
Mayo is is easy to make
uh I remember I was making this is a
long time ago back in the 90s or after I
got out of the army I was working in a
really good kitchen for like about a
year and a half
and Pass Christian Mississippi right
there on the [ __ ]
water had a young Chef who's just out of
school with his partner and we and we
were kicking ass all right making a lot
of money uh well he was I wasn't making
a lot of money but [ __ ] we were
[ __ ] killing the [ __ ] town every
night was like a [ __ ] rock concert
and I was [ __ ] back a house
and made all the salad dressings made
the Mayo made all the condiments
um made all the [ __ ] bread and then
Made bread pudding on top of that
um that was basically what I was doing I
did that [ __ ] full time
and I remember making
Mayo but I don't remember what the exact
recipe was
I made it I would [ __ ] I'd boil up
all these eggs in the morning
bust them open take all the yolks out we
use the yolks for something else but I
forgot what it was
and then uh for a certain [ __ ] amount
of weight of [ __ ] egg whites you had
to put a certain amount of [ __ ]
cheese right oil and vinegar
and I would turn that into
it haven't been a big old metal Bowl
I would turn that into [ __ ] Mayo
using a whisk
I did it with a whisk
that's how badass I was back then
and it took it forever you couldn't use
a blender it had to be done with a whisk
a metal whisk
and before you knew it that [ __ ] was
like after about 15 minutes later we're
[ __ ] whisking that [ __ ] it would be
May Mayo
like you've never seen before
not out of any jar or any squeeze bottle
nothing you could buy
Mayo that was so good
you could take a ice cream scoop
and get a [ __ ] a whole bunch of that
mayo and throw it into a [ __ ] bowl
and then grab a [ __ ] spoon and eat it
all that's how good it was
you couldn't do that with Miracle Whip
or helmets you get sick you'd be like uh
but no real Mayo made by hand is so good
that you're just like oh yeah and that
was the original recipe
and with that
that was the foundation for other salad
dressings I was making and we also just
had Mayo too but I had to make lots of
that lots of it I had to make like five
gallons of mayo a week
maybe more
to keep the restaurant running because
that's all I did was I was like I was
like a Saucier just like out of [ __ ]
uh Apocalypse Now [ __ ] with this
[ __ ] the chef Saucier yeah right
there near New Orleans all I did was
make sauces and condiments
and that was a good gig
it was a good gig
I gotta touch up on all that I haven't
thought about it in a long time because
you buy that [ __ ] you know what I mean
don't think about me I mean it's much
easier it's much easier to buy it right
because I could make ketchup
it was his recipe but I was making
[ __ ] I got his catch the ketchup I
was making was [ __ ] you could pour it
in a coffee mug and drink it that's how
good it was
I could do that anyway I love ketchup
and then the the ketchup was the basis
we used to catch up too
but he
make the ketchup and then like [ __ ]
half of it ended up being used in
barbecue sauce
and then the barbecue sauce had a bunch
of [ __ ] Jack Daniels in it
and you had to use you had to cook that
down and sometimes I was cooking 10
gallons of [ __ ] barbecue sauce down
well you know back in the day Chili's
the chain restaurant had a I think if
they had Jack Daniel's Grill yeah so
they had all that and it was actually
pretty good I don't know if they're
still doing it or not that was a long
time ago I've been in Chili's in a while
I think it was Chili's I've got to get
back on my Saucier game yeah you should
yeah
Camp guy said I found a better than
bullion soup base I've heard a lot of
good things about that brand I don't
think we've ever used it
um he's like they this was Italian herb
flavored
and he says he has mushroom-based
Lobster base sauteed onion base beef and
chicken stock base vegetable broth base
garlic base I really like that product
line yeah I I do feel like a lot of
people like I said a lot of cooking
channels that I watch like they usually
will use that a lot they seem to like it
John Smith said this made me laugh if
you ever read the letters of H.P
Lovecraft he writes a letter to an aunt
about a Walk on the Wild Side in which
she goes to an Italian restaurant and
tries this exotic dish called ravioli oh
hell yeah
I can't believe that he actually would
go and do that like he'd think that it
was totally weird that Betty Crocker
cookbook that I have downstairs
they have a foreign food section
and in that section is a subsection
called Italian
and in that Italian section they teach
you how to make [ __ ] marinara sauce
Italian
tomato sauce yeah
and basically the only Spice in that
sauce outside of [ __ ] salt pepper and
garlic is oregano and they have a whole
[ __ ] paragraph explaining to you what
oregano is
that's quaint that's so cute well it's
just like oregano well because I mean I
you know I was born like I was a kid
like probably at the tail end of that
yeah but I do remember in the 70s
Italian food still see being seen as
like somewhat foreign you know what I
mean I think by the time I was a kid it
was more kind of like Chinese food and
Mexican food was more seen like foreign
like Italian food wasn't that weird but
yeah still anything like Asian or
anything like that people like ooh
exotic like oh basically like the only
Asian food that I had grown up was that
like La Choy [ __ ] that was in that big
can you know
now the the method
The Culinary method that conquered the
Earth is the French method all right and
there's there were competing French
methods but it has to do with mother
sauces and cooking and everything but
the French style is basically the
western style a lot of the British stuff
actually is kind of French
because medieval England looks to France
during all this time especially during
the Renaissance
so in white boy cooking French it's the
French really and that's what they teach
you in like right if you go to cooking
school yeah that's usually what they
teach you and that's everywhere that's
spread throughout the Earth
but that's mostly has to do with their
system okay
um which there is a system on okay
on the organization of cooking inside a
kitchen
but when it comes to [ __ ] the flavors
that conquered the Earth
it's Mexican Italian and Indian
those guys have got they've I mean those
are kind of like those are the ones I
feel like they got
those guys are the masters of well
Indians are the masters of spice
they can take nothing and make it taste
[ __ ] great just on the back of spices
and I'm saying if you are going to be a
vegetarian or a vegan yeah learn how to
cook Indian food because man they make
the best vegetarian and vegan food of
anybody I feel like the Mexicans can too
and never miss me the Mexicans can take
two basic [ __ ] things which is corn
and pork all right and bait on the back
of porn and cook porn on the back of
corn and pork okay now put porn on there
too poor Decor
on the back of [ __ ] pork and corn
the Mexicans will [ __ ] feed the [ __ ]
out of you all right they can come up
with all kinds of stuff it's [ __ ]
great
Cuisine good instincts a lot of [ __ ]
practical experience with Mexican
recipes all right if you guys want to
learn if you're if you're outside
the Mexican Realm
you want to go on YouTube and go cooking
con Claudia look for her and she'll
teach you how to cook [ __ ] great
Mexican food at home all right they're
not it's not hard to get a hold of those
components it's just a style
the Mexicans and the Indians okay look I
hate I always like to say this [ __ ] is
true
but don't take it the wrong way the
Mexicans and the Indians are the [ __ ]
the kings of poor people food
where you take nothing and turn it into
a [ __ ] but like I said I think all
food is the is about poor people food
really and honestly to me all about that
that to me seems like harder it's harder
because like if you have like the best
you know ingredients then I'll change
nothing it's easy to make that taste
good because it's the best ingredients
if you have like nothing to work with
and you can still make that I mean it
taste good Exquisite then that is like
way way harder I think if you have
fantastic ingredients
the challenge is to restrain yourself
from doing something because you have a
great ingredient
you got to resist the urge to change it
yeah [ __ ] speak for itself right
you don't do it the ingredient is good
that is a badass steak don't change
anything well they're just talking about
Ambassador staff they're like look that
is a beautiful piece of me why are you
[ __ ] up like that don't change it
right but overthinking it right you quit
complicating it but like I said if you
have like but I that's another thing I
kind of like about MasterChef one of my
favorite things that they did this past
season was they basically said you have
to make a gourmet meal out of [ __ ] you
can buy in a gas station which that's
the challenge like I said and that to me
is way harder it's easy to make really
really good ingredients taste good
because they already taste good you
don't have to do much to them but taking
like a bunch of like [ __ ] and making
that taste good that's a whole other
level in Mexico what you're dealing with
is corn corn is not expensive
they got lots of it so you gotta Elevate
corn to turn that into tortillas okay
which is that boy there's a lot of
different ways you can come and come at
tortillas you can make corn tortillas
you can make gorditas you can [ __ ]
because you're adding something to make
it rise a little bit which is kind of
like Mexican cornbread
then you can take flour make flour
tortillas
and that right there that's your bread
that's your [ __ ] base okay
and then you're dealing with pork
and you may not be dealing with the
[ __ ] choices parts of pork they might
be second rate or third rate cuts of
pork
but you got you got the flavor [ __ ]
flavor profiles and the cooking
techniques and everything to turn that
into [ __ ] top notch beautiful Taste
of food
so the Mexicans got that down to a
[ __ ]
science okay and then there's a long
history behind it a lot of these [ __ ]
recipes like Carnitas and [ __ ] like that
go back to the [ __ ] 15 1600s
before the Spaniards arrived okay before
the pig arrived
and you'll find out that those recipes
originally
included the flesh from human sacrifices
people Tacos yeah
and that was only for rich people okay
guys at the top of the damn Mexican food
chain you know they cut your heart out
and everything on top of those temples
and that meat didn't go to waste it
ended up on people's tables all right
so they were like the Vikings okay the
Mexicans were [ __ ] Macho about this
[ __ ] this is these are this is Viking
[ __ ] going on here you know what I mean
and
the pig replaced
human flesh okay
and that's why all this stuff with the
cartels and everything this is nothing
new with the Mexicans that's them
returning to their [ __ ] origins of
basically being [ __ ] Central American
Vikings you know they're badasses I just
got to respect the culture you know but
uh no hell yes
now that they got the pig
and they're still dealing with Maize and
they can come up with all different
kinds of sauce tomatillos and making
great green Salsas and uh
[ __ ] Tequilas and it's a macho food
very flavorful
it's
not
healthy and large quantities but most
real good ones nothing is yeah really
yeah it's about like Southern food
um because [ __ ] my dad was born with a
[ __ ] baby bottle in his mouth [ __ ]
half filled with [ __ ] pork drippings
make that [ __ ] healthy you know [ __ ]
that's just the way the hair on your
chest you know put some hair on your
chest beef him up some you know that's
the thing man like this out they were
just kind of like what what you're not
having seconds or thirds are you saying
yeah it's the same culture are you sick
you have to like clean your plate once
or twice yeah or they think there's
something to matter with you yeah which
is why there's so many fat people down
here because they do that for like right
from when you're kids so they probably
don't do it anymore but they used to the
Mexicans are the masters of uh
pork
pork and corn
the uh the Indians are the masters of
vegetables and spices they can take a
vegetarian dish and just or take a dish
that has just a little bit of lamb and
it make you just like you have a [ __ ]
Feast you know to be honest if all I
could eat was Indian food it's like I
would probably not even miss me I mean
you know I'm not saying that because I
do really like like some of the Indian
dishes that have meat in them like
butter chicken they got the best
vegetarian lamb Masala but they're
vegetarian stuff like all the stuff they
do with paneer and stuff like because I
[ __ ] love paneer yeah like all of
that stuff is just [ __ ] delicious I
could just eat that and I'd probably
like never even think about eating meat
now Italian American foods they're what
they're doing is their mat they're
mastering the tomato
tomato tomato and sausages all right
they're real good with that
and um but when you talk about Italian
food back in Italy
it's a lot lighter it's pastas with uh
not much sauce on it a lot of seafood
it's more a lot more Mediterranean
flavor which is good too I like that
it's good too that kind of stuff both
ways are good just that Italian American
food is pimped out it's pimped out
they're just they're they're they're
they're they're they're they're they're
going for the more is better philosophy
yeah tomatoes and put a lot put more you
know which that's
that was the mentality of the time it
stands up but there's two different
versions of Italian Italian back in
Italy and Italian America
there are two different versions of it
John Smith said there's a great podcast
called voluminous which is an analysis
of lovecraft's letters I'm gonna have to
write that down because that sounds like
totally something I would be into
listening to so thank you for that
there's so many like good [ __ ]
podcasts I wish I had more time to like
yeah Camp guys that I like straight up
vegetarian Indian food no meat yeah I
mean honestly like I said their stuff
with meat is good too because I really
like like shrimp Masala and I really
like like lamb all the lamb dishes that
they do and chicken and stuff but all
the stuff they do with paneer is
fantastic like I love all that kind of
stuff yeah uh Victor Garcia is saying
that [ __ ] yeah it's it's uh tortillas
and Frijoles which is uh beans refried
beans
which uh beans are shelf stable they
[ __ ] keep forever slow cook them
right you season them right high protein
food where you uh can keep you alive if
you're in poverty [ __ ] beans they'll
just keep you [ __ ] running well what
I was gonna say is that if you're rich
eating a lot of it you get fat but well
yeah but what I was going to say that is
that pretty much every because I'm kind
of fascinated by like I said I'm
interested in
people's limitations and how they kind
of get over the limitations so a lot of
the videos that I like about cooking
that are like you know I fed up myself
for like five dollars for like one week
yeah 95 of the stuff that they is beans
and rice is Mexican food yeah like
because you can get beans rice tortillas
for like super cheap and you can make
like a whole bunch of different [ __ ]
about that if I'm not with that I got 30
pounds of [ __ ] uh maseka I can make
[ __ ] tortillas all [ __ ] day
uh and and it
a tortilla will fill you up
you know what I mean and and put free
and then Victor says that [ __ ] uh
cooking con Claudia he also [ __ ] says
that yeah if you want to learn how to
cook Mexican food go see uh Claudia
cooking come Claudia and he comments
that how how cute she is she's cute
she's in her early 30s cute Mexican girl
and it's all in English so
um and she explains why they do certain
things
so if you're a non-mexican you want to
learn how to cook Mexican food check out
Claudia on YouTube cooking concludia
very easy recipes
she shows you how to do it and you can
back it up and watch it over again
and how to start with base materials
like how to make salsa out of peppers
how to roast [ __ ] Peppers to make
salsa
you know she the very very Basics and
then she starts with there and then
she'll go into more and more advanced
stuff but she's a good teacher
good great show
said I love Tabasco habanero sauce also
go with pasta and Italian food to spice
it up easy to make
um easy to make I can't really eat that
because it gives me like really really
bad heartburn so all that is is that you
take
peppers
and you cook them
slowly boil them in vinegar add a little
bit of salt and blend it together just
the ratios have to be right
then you put a little
funnel down into a bottle and you pour
it all in there now a true Louisiana hot
sauce you're going to strain it through
a wire strainer
and then it'll end up being just like
Tabasco and you can adjust the salt
vinegar Ratio or the [ __ ] spice like
I got a bunch of Carolina Reapers down
there came out of my garden I got to
make something like that out of them
before they go bad
gonna be [ __ ] Reaper sauce that [ __ ]
God damn you could probably like set up
a little thing like the like the booth
we saw now like earlier today like set
up on the side of the road selling the
pot boiled peanuts yeah yeah and
um make a few bucks doing that yeah
but you don't have to strain it there
there are tutorials on how to make
things like Tabasco
Tabasco is expensive now
I remember when to own a bottle of
Tabasco was only a couple dollars now
it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] like [ __ ] five
bucks for a [ __ ] bottle tobacco well
everybody got in on it that's why that's
the thing it's like back in the old days
when like nobody knew anything about
that much about food and it's like oh
this [ __ ] was all exotic and everything
but see now everybody knows everything
about everything like everybody's a
foodie y'all are buying up all the
Tabasco
last time I was in Mississippi in
Louisiana area they couldn't even afford
it afford Tobasco they had to buy
Crystal most places just buy are buying
Crystal which is
Crystal and red hot Crystal's better
than red hot but it's a similar kind of
sauce I mean I kind of feel like
Crystal's pretty exciting Crystal's
about like Tabasco well like I said I'm
not
I've never really been a fan of like
really really hot stuff like I can eat
hot sauce to an extent but usually it
just like [ __ ] my stomach up and it's
like not seems like it's not worth it
most of the time
yeah because it just kind of like
overwhelms to me it just like overwhelms
whatever the flavor of whatever you put
it on like I know some people like it
like I'm not saying a lot of people like
it but I'm not really into it it's just
I don't know it's too hot I can't eat it
and it like I said it it's not worth the
the pain that I'll be going through
later
because I get really bad I get really
bad heartburn
um yeah let's see uh Camp guy said easy
to make the Olive Garden copycat pasta
facial bean soup several recipes on
YouTube yeah pretty much anything that
any restaurant sells
um there's a dupe out there somewhere
and you can find it on the internet
so
there's a dupe for the cheddar bay
biscuits actually you can buy those that
you can buy that mix at
um the store I don't know if they're as
good as the ones in the restaurant
though but I don't know
but yeah there's a dupe for pretty much
anything I like I like those like those
videos too I was watching a video the
other day where she was doing a dupe of
like a bunch of
the Starbucks drinks like how you can
make them for a lot cheaper
you know but
I haven't done any of it yet because I'm
lazy
but you know
I'm just kind of like I want all this
stuff but I'm just like
do I really have time to do that not
really
I basically have
I don't know I bought I have like a big
thing of like McDonald's coffee because
I do like their coffee so I bought like
a big can of that I have like a smaller
can like to celebrate fall I bought
myself some pumpkin spice like Headless
Horseman coffee that's pretty good
and I also have
um I have some beans like from a local
place that I still haven't used because
I gotta grind them
so haven't done that yet okay if you all
are tired of the food talk you can just
drop another question in the comment
section we can change subjects but for
the time being looks like we're on food
I mean as long as everybody's talking
about food nobody's buying it so I heard
a couple of them in there complaining
what is this a food show yeah it's a
food show it's it's any kind of it's any
kind of show look if it's just one
comment then I'm just gonna ignore that
if everybody's bitching yeah then okay
but
no one's bitching no one's bitching
the thing about food is that the food
like the great unit everybody got to eat
right yeah everybody got to eat and
everybody has like their own opinions
about it yesterday uh or it's a day
before yesterday I cooked a damn whole
chicken
we ate half of it the other half I
pulled it pulled all the meat off of it
chopped it up
made chicken salad with tarragon
dried cranberries man that stuff saying
yeah yeah and chickens I had a chicken
salad sandwich for lunch eat chicken
salad we got back from me with mayo yeah
well see that's you made it Wednesday
night because remember at the end of the
show right you were baking a chicken
yeah at the on Wednesday's show and then
a lot of it left yeah I had to laugh the
show I had like a thigh and a leg and
then you made like some potatoes and
some broccoli and stuff like that and
that was really good we had that after
the show and then I didn't even know
last night we were in there watching uh
that show on Hulu like the those History
Channel shows like the toys that made
America or whatever Built America or
whatever and you were like oh hey by the
way I made chicken salad out of the rest
of that chicken that I baked and I was
like you did what what yeah I love
chicken salad yeah got a bunch of it
down I was like maybe a [ __ ] sandwich
then
you have some after this after the
[ __ ] show oh I probably will like I
said we you know we had uh yeah we had
one for on like that wheat is it wheat
Pita was that just regular Peter it was
just regular yeah it seemed like wheat
regular peanut but that was good but I
got wheat but we're not into that yet oh
okay I see we're just trying to get up
to yeah I knew we had bought some wheat
pizza I haven't even opened that yet oh
okay
yeah that's that shit's delicious that
chicken salad
yeah with all the nuts yeah and after it
sits there for about a day and the
Cranberries kind of [ __ ] sop up the
[ __ ] moisture from the Mayo
that's just good when we were we talk
about food all the time like when we're
not on the show too because we were
coming back from
Lowe's in the liquor store yeah and Tom
suddenly asks me
where'd you get those coconut shrimp
from before yeah and I said uh yeah it's
maybe it was Red Lobster I don't
remember but we were eating somewhere
and I got coconut shrimp because I love
coconut shrimp and he was like you know
we bought some tilapia fillets it's like
maybe I could do like a coconut coconut
tilapia tilapia and I was talking about
things into nuggets like tilapia nuggets
oh my God
that sounds good and then I said then
well you have to make like the orange
marmalade sauce that goes with it
because that kind of I mean you know
coconut shrimp are good on their own
yeah but the orange marmalade sauce mom
related that just takes it over the top
marmalade and then put some like uh
white wine vinegar in it
and turn it into almost kind of like
chicken Chinese duck sauce and make a
dipping sauce out of it
that's probably how that should go oh my
God that'd be so good yeah
I'm a big seafood fan yeah I'm a big
seafood fan rice pilaf
what about rice pilaf it'd be a good
side for that yeah you don't like rice
pilaf I'm not it's okay I'm good I'm not
a big fan look at Pookie pants
what you doing
yeah you want to be on the show book
what time is it it's it's not late
not even two hours not even two hours
okay hour and 45 minutes why are you
getting bored almost
is a long show two hours is a long show
not really for his Side Tracks though
yeah I kind of feel like our way getting
these people ready to go out our
Wednesday night show yeah ended up being
four hours oh man that's just [ __ ]
ridiculous four hours is ridiculous
some people love it though I have a good
time on this though because this well
the Friday night show is a lot less like
I said it's a lot less stressful for me
because I don't
have to like worry about staying on
topic or is moonshine is slamming
like I said now this is a different
brand I for some reason when we bought
it I didn't realize I didn't realize
it's still good though because they did
have big jars of like the brand that we
bought yeah the one that we got last
time he didn't even see it like I bought
it on the way out I was like at the
checkout and they you know they have in
the liquor store if you go to liquor
store they have like a big um thing of
like all the little 99 cent samples
and they had like a little bitty tiny
jar it was like apple pie moonshine oh
[ __ ] yeah I was like I gotta get that so
it was 99 Cents so I got that and like
we had on the show I'm like oh my God
that's delicious so when we went back to
ABC today
we were looking for the Moonshine and
they did have a big jar of it from that
brand which like I think they were
called midnight Midnight Moon but this
brand is different that's like old
smokey it's still good but it's still
good it tastes like pretty much the same
it's close I think I think this one
might this one's stronger in cinnamon
the other one was more Appley a little
talk more tart yeah I agree with you on
that I agree with that I think you know
what the other one tasted A Little Bit
Stronger like this one's pretty strong
not saying that but I feel like the
other one at least on the front end when
you first sipped it yeah it was a lot
more like overwhelming like moonshiny
and then you'd get the apple pie this
one is over it's it's very strong but
it's like it's mellower you just want it
on the Rocks a little bit don't mix that
with anything just on the rocks
okay that's it
that's it that's some redneck [ __ ] right
there that's some Cowboy [ __ ]
although the Cowboys didn't know about
moonshine because moonshine kind of came
out of prohibition next time we'll get
those moonshine cherries yeah I wouldn't
mind the peach I don't want to try the
pizza well you can get the peach so I'll
get the cherries you like Peach I like
Cherry the pickles are probably good and
pickles are good too yeah I mean I like
pickles
it has a whole jar of pickles filled
with moonshine
quite good it's how can that be bad I
feel like a dirty martini yeah how could
that be bad yeah I don't see how that
could be bad
Hugo said you guys should do a Sidetrack
show in the kitchen so Tom can cook and
eat
yeah that sounds easy to do but that's
hard to do because there's a lot of
times involved I mean it's it's a lot
better if it's edited
and then lighting for a kitchen is
[ __ ] difficult to do we'd have to get
boom lights and stuff
that's the thing I do kind of feel like
a lot of the channels that I watch while
they're kind of like lower rent but yeah
they kind of have the whole setup where
they right you got to have to stand up
yeah and they have like several like
with the you know they have bad the
stuff where you can like go down into
the pan and all like right so if it's a
lot of like thinking about it
looks easier than it actually is I don't
have a lot of focus for that kind of
like right for that kind of
Shenanigans it'd be much easier for me
to record me making something
and then posting the video
not live we should probably do that one
of these days like if you're gonna make
something like impressive
yeah I can record you doing it and then
I could I edit it
you know what I mean yeah well [ __ ] I
could even edit it and put it up on
patreon
just as a thank you Victor for the boom
lights fund
what's up Victor thanks man because a
lot of cooking is just kind of like
sitting around waiting yeah right yeah
or like boring kind of [ __ ] so I kind of
feel like it's better if it's edited a
little bit because nobody wants to like
just sit around watching somebody like
chop up [ __ ] peppers I gotta make
carnitas tomorrow Victor I got a [ __ ]
pork butt already thawed got a
cook that [ __ ] and he is the pop
I I use [ __ ] um Claudius carnitas
instapot recipe actually it's good
I have to say I mean all of your like
carnies because we've made like many
different iterations of it yeah I made a
bunch of different versions I think that
hers yeah is the best one they're more
subtle it's mild yeah but that's good
because you can use it in a lot of
different applications which I like it's
not like super super spicy like I said I
have a problem with that anyway like you
know my digestive system yeah but I
don't know it's just it's really really
good it's just really Savory you get
some spice in there but it's not like
overwhelming and if you want to put it
in other things that aren't necessarily
you could even put it like in a regular
dish that wasn't necessarily like
Mexican right coated and it would still
be good
so it's pork pork pulled pork meat yeah
I yeah I kind of feel like it actually
brings out the flavor of the meat but
see I like that
I don't you know I know some people like
like really spicy stuff but
I kind of like to I like spices that
just enhance the flavor of what's there
like the meat and don't overwhelm it
yeah a lot of the Mexican stuff that
I've found over time
you find out less is more
when it comes to spice
and that's kind of more authentic to
what's happening in Mexico
it's not as much spice as people think
now you're talking about cow mix or
Tex-Mex they've added a lot of spicing
to it
which wasn't there
in the original recipe they're both good
but for general purpose I like the
Mexican versions better
they're a little more mild
now what will be hot will be
Salsas that they put on them they'll put
[ __ ] you know what I mean yeah well
that's what I'm saying like if you're
gonna make that much meat at once yeah
it makes more sense to just make the
spicing on the meat like miles and
everybody can eat it and then one
everybody can eat it and two you can use
it over Mal over several days and do
multiple dishes dishes and if you want
something that's like more spicy like
you said you can do like a spicy or
salsa or you can like put you know cut
up jalapenos or whatever the [ __ ] you
want to put on there to like match it to
your spice level whereas like you know
wimps like me that aren't really into
like super spicy food yeah you can still
eat it in other applications Victor I
got these [ __ ]
I got 10 of these peppers I pulled out
of my garden man
they're beyond hot
they're the hottest pepper in the world
they're hotter than anything in Mexico
man y'all would [ __ ] love them
they're called Carolina Reapers
they're hotter than [ __ ] ghost
peppers
and they make great salsa I'm gonna make
I'm gonna make a salsa out of them but
that shit's gonna just don't touch your
eyes out yeah
you'll be hating life I got enough of
them where I can make something like a
salsa and then I can make something like
a Tabasco
and we'll see
I have enough of them where I could
probably make three different hot sauces
and have huge jars of it because you've
got to break it down it's so hot you
can't
you can't go pure with that you got to
dilute it
much hotter than a habanero much hotter
I mean if you want me to like make some
labels for the [ __ ] you could like you
could do like a little Boutique business
with that I thought about it thought
about it yeah I thought about it we'll
see if there's a demand I can make
I'll make you a label I'll make you a
website I'll make all kind of [ __ ] I can
do all those plants are out there
kicking ass but I gotta get recipes
right first
I gotta make the [ __ ] get the recipes
right and go yeah this and that and this
and that and I'd do it custom
uh for a listener I do that [ __ ] custom
I have a custom label on it and
everything
send that [ __ ] in a box in a pretty ass
[ __ ] bottle
yeah
yeah I would do like a whole thing for
that I would do a whole time I got three
or four different peppers out there I
got Serranos out there I got jalapenos
[ __ ] cook uh growing and I got
Carolina Reapers
yeah
we'll see
I mean I kind of I told you before like
you should totally start like a little
an eggplant or kicking ass I got more
eggplant coming we're just gonna have to
eat this what can we like well what can
we make and sell that's eggplant no
based they don't keep you guys got to
cook them uh what I'm gonna do with this
next eggplant remember when I did the
eggplant when can we make like baba
ganoush like jar you can make yeah but
it doesn't keep it doesn't keep
because we have so many eggplants you
guys
Jesus Christ I like it well if you get
if I got four people ordering then I
wouldn't have enough it's just
but uh
yeah we haven't had baba ganoush in a
while haven't
and I got all those onions I I should
probably make some baba ganoush but I
don't have any uh tahini I had to go
down and buy some that's okay okay
and then um get some more pita
all right I could do that
you guys said if you like rum I want to
recommend you my two favorites Appleton
Jamaican rum okay and Havana Club seven
year Cuban rum I think we can see either
one of those at ABC well I'm sure they
probably have them yeah it's not like I
was like super looking
like I said when we were at the store
like
that ABC is so big that I kind of get
overwhelmed like I said I gotta I kind
of get distracted by because I'm a
graphic designer so I get all into like
the label designs and the bottle designs
I was like oh look this vodka has a
bottle that looks like an alien head
yeah and I'm super into that this is
what we got right now Palms
they had a bunch of flavors like [ __ ]
Savage these are like mid-tier and it's
like they were on sale yeah and we're
like well let's get those because we
haven't had that break yeah so let's try
it they were only like [ __ ] 11 bucks
a bottle they were on sale yeah uh what
was the um
where's it made
uh please don't let me drop this
you know what I don't know
are you all gonna tell me some [ __ ] yeah
it's got to be on there somewhere
um
man that's Minnesota right Minnesota
this shit's made in Minnesota oh we're
gonna throw that [ __ ] out
we're gonna throw that [ __ ] we got
[ __ ]
Minnesota tropical rum made in Minnesota
made in Minnesota
and they're selling that [ __ ] to Florida
my heart's broken
if I if I think it might be good it
might be good though it might be good
honestly I did want I did want to like
get the Saint Augustine stuff but it was
so like cost prohibitive
maybe it's worth it I don't know but
like when I was with the dollar [ __ ]
fifth or something that's what I'm
saying like when I was going around
going that's twice because like I said I
told you guys we did a whole show about
like the [ __ ] [ __ ] I did like a week
I was in St Augustine I was like oh they
have The Distillery and I was like oh
I'll do a tour one of these days I
should have bought some booze while I
was there but I didn't and
um so they have it at the store but
55 dollars for a fifth of bourbon they
make gin they make all they make all
different stuff too I think they make
vodka yeah
but I remember the bourbon was 54.99 and
I was like Jesus Christ that I don't
know is is it worth it I don't know now
we're now we're [ __ ] on a subject
that I want to [ __ ] discuss real
quick okay
that's all right
you know how you have all these people
who are wine tasters they show up and
they taste these ones oh this is a
fantastic book all that shit's been
debunked they've been done [ __ ] taste
tests with those dudes okay
and they basically select Wines that
taste good
it doesn't matter how that wine was made
they can't tell the difference okay
they're looking for certain tastes
in the olden days
the wine making and booze making process
wasn't very sanitary
so a lot of times you could buy a bottle
of wine from a [ __ ] mid-tier or kind
of an inferior maker and some of that
[ __ ] tasted bad because it kind of
became like vinegar all right
or it was just shitty tasting
and that was considered to be an
inferior wine
a superior wine would have a [ __ ] a
better success rate because the seals
were better on the bottles there's more
sanitation to happen inside the factory
the bottles are clean before the [ __ ]
wine went in there or it's a bunch of
different factors
if you were to go down
to Walmart
and buy one of them damn boxes of wine
it's like ten dollar box of wine and
give that to a [ __ ] medieval king or
a [ __ ] King in the Renaissance
[ __ ] era of [ __ ] like 1400s 1300s
and gave that to a [ __ ] King he'd say
that was the best [ __ ] wine in the
world okay well that's what they were
looking for even our cheap [ __ ] nowadays
yeah well because yeah we have laws yeah
we have standards yeah
um even if like [ __ ] is like super cheap
it might not taste fantastic yeah but at
least you know like it's clean and it's
probably been produced like to some like
standard and stuff like that so they
didn't have that back then yeah so I do
kind of feel like I don't know
I will say that I can tell the
difference between
real bottom of the barrel like bottom
shelf stuff yeah that just tastes like
rubbing alcohol
but once you get to like the second
third shelf up yeah I can't tell the
difference right this stuff maybe some
other people came but people who have
[ __ ] really looked into this with a
critical eye it's like art [ __ ]
appreciation okay
people have looked at this with a
scientific and critical eye will tell
you basically nowadays all this [ __ ]
you're drinking is safe
okay in general it's safe you're not
gonna [ __ ] kill yeah you're fine get
killed drinking this so that's one of
the [ __ ] big hurdles out of the way
because it wasn't safe back then okay so
you have to worry about that
what what it's up to now is whether or
not you like it if you drink it and like
it then it's good sure all right I'll
proved that a couple weeks back when I
[ __ ] grab that [ __ ] cult Malt
Liquor 45 45 which was perfectly
delicious it was [ __ ] yeah totally
drinkable yeah totally drinkables good
[ __ ]
and you got to look at the you got to
look at the price comparisons
if you only have a dollar something
here in the United States your choices
will be bud
coolers the real piss water beers
all right and then maybe that colt 45.
I'd rather have them all liquor than
that for a dollar or something it tastes
better this tastes better
is it beer I don't know a small liquor
I don't really care how they made
anything I don't know I don't care how
they made it it was high in alcohol
content the quality was good it tasted
good it was a good drinking experience
for the money you want to go for that
all right
um
back in the day when I was a kid you
know what I mean [ __ ] you know my my
white boys would be like no don't drink
that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's terrible stuff
they didn't want you to find out that it
was out yeah they're like that's not
beer
black dudes drink that don't [ __ ]
drink that that's well the black dudes
had it right it did they had it right
either it's like whatever white people
more for us yeah yeah in in that price
segment you want to go with [ __ ] Malt
Liquor I mean that tasted way better
than what I remember like Bud or [ __ ]
yeah uh Malt Liquor the cheap malt
liquor was a lot better than cheap beer
yeah now when you start going into
[ __ ] you start moving up in price you
start going into micro brewery beer
yeah you're going to want to go with
that this is the [ __ ] three dollar
four dollar [ __ ] per bottle beer you
know what I mean you're you're but when
we're talking a dollar some no [ __ ] them
all liquor
is that beer probably not no it's a beer
like substance
that's the reason why dudes would turn
in there but it tastes better still
tastes better it didn't matter you're
still gonna get drunk sure so some of
this stuff applies to hard liquor
that some of these flavored Jim beams
like what was that called Jim Beam Honey
Jim Beam [ __ ] that Jim Beam apple
green apple or that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
good it was good real good and that's
inexpensive that's very [ __ ]
affordably Pride it was very affordable
the you know [ __ ] 15 bucks for a
fifth of that [ __ ] less Maybe
price is [ __ ] right
man 30 years ago you would never be able
to get a flavor like that
and I don't care if that might be a
artificial flavoring in there
what do I care
I'm into the drinking experience did it
taste good
did it taste good did it mix well with
the other stuff
did I catch a buzz on it did I have a
good drinking experience with Jim Beam
Apple yeah I did I did I did as well
yeah
so all this stuff is a miracle it's a
modern Miracle compared to what was
around 40 years ago 30 years ago
the the selection's a lot better and a
lot more affordable I mean I'm not
really inclined to be picky I'm not I
didn't actually start drinking until I
was older so I don't really have any
I don't know I don't have a lot of the
maybe prejudices that like some other
people have about oh this is like we
don't drink that or yeah I don't know I
don't know if that's still a thing
nowadays but I don't really have any of
that so I'm just kind of like I'll buy
whatever if it sounds okay and like try
it out and if it tastes good I'll say it
tastes good and I'm like yeah that's
good I don't give a [ __ ] if like
hipsters don't you don't like it or
something
you know well I don't know I don't I
don't really know what's going on I can
go and get like uh
a bottle of
she worked for um Van Gogh vodka and I
did Van Gogh's [ __ ] selling point she
did a lot of the graphic design and
stuff [ __ ]
she took me to her [ __ ] company
dinner remember that I was there with
all the [ __ ] van Gogh that's right
yeah
it was a nice little dinner that was
before they started laying everybody off
okay because Pinnacle was kicking that
ass and that's what I'm gonna get at
Van Gogh had good craft
vodkas
they were flavored
they tasted pretty good all their stuff
was natural flavors natural they were
very proud of that no artificial flavors
but what they were up against was
Pinnacle yeah and Pinnacle was
artificially flavored came in a plastic
bottle
a lot cheaper
yeah like half the price or less than
half the price yeah and I must say
Pinnacle tasted better
some flavors some flavors some flavors
some flavors they tasted better and on
the back of those flavors it kicked Van
Gogh's ass
that Pinnacle [ __ ] whipped cream was
[ __ ] great you could mix that with
anything that sounds delicious the
birthday cake one's pretty good too yeah
it was an artificial flavored but I
don't know it's still good
there is a magic of Art and there's a
certain magic behind artificial
artificiality [ __ ] you know what I
mean it's just like science [ __ ] it's
just like titties you know what I mean
yeah they got some badass natural
titties but then again some [ __ ] fake
titties show up and those [ __ ]
are just badass it's it's Aesthetics you
know same thing with taste it depends on
what you're looking for
now
Pinnacle one out
although van goes back Jenny and I we we
saw it at [ __ ] ABC tonight okay now
like ABC I was curious so I went and
looked yeah they're absent this back
well that was they didn't make that yeah
they just distributed it I don't know if
they're still Distributing it because
that whole like this Distribution
Company is it was expensive
they do still have lucid they've
redesigned their bottle but I like the
redesign it's very it's classy I'm into
it I liked the minimalist [ __ ] they had
going on back in the you know mid 2000s
or mid-2010s I guess but the new design
is nice though it's kind of like this
big tall bottle and they have like this
raised metal shield type situation going
on and I was like oh I like that I like
that it's very very classy now Van Gogh
though is still around because at ABC
they had one Van Gogh flavor which was
espresso I feel like that was their that
was a good flavor well that was their
best-selling flavor I kind of feel like
they had a couple their espresso vodka
is delicious you can drink that by
itself Van Gogh caramel was good we had
yeah all the flavors were good I'm just
saying their espresso was my favorite
some of them weren't as good as Pinnacle
but [ __ ] Vago caramel was better than
pinnacle yeah Vego peanut peanut butter
and jelly was [ __ ] good but it didn't
taste like jelly just did like peanut
butter I like that one
and then uh what was the other one that
was that I liked
the berry ones I didn't they were just
not impressive to me remember they had
like a blueberry one yeah they had
blueberry they had raspberry
they were good but they didn't really
there wasn't enough difference to
justify I think like the price flavor
wasn't quite strong enough
because they're using all natural
flavoring
so you're going to limit you
there's something to be said about
artificiality and some of those flavors
well it like I said it's like anything
else it depends like what are you gonna
do with this like I said if I'm gonna
mix this artificial's the way to go then
yeah then I want like a really strong
flavor so I want like an artificial
flavor because yeah the natural flavors
are good if you're just gonna drink them
straight yeah they're actually much
better but if you're going to mix them
with orange juice or whatever then yeah
they're artificial ones better so what
I'm trying to get down to people is that
uh don't do not be bamboozled
by what they say when it comes to booze
and alcohol and beer
if you like it it's good
if you like it it's good
like I had those damn Mexican Micheladas
when I was buying them what was the name
of that company
um
and now I can't remember
yeah that's right
when I was buying them they were like oh
yeah that stuff that's you know yeah
it's kind of like not good but no I made
it the way it was with salted the rim
put the ice in there pulled the models
out got a [ __ ] on video that [ __ ] was
great it was good actually yeah if it
was a great drinking experience it was
like a mixed drink kind of made out of
beer we got we got orange and then
pineapple pineapple and mango and mango
and they all had spice backs like mango
habanero and [ __ ] this and that all
of them were good I think the pineapple
was my favorite but they were all right
now later on kind of Awesome from
[ __ ] Mexico jumps in and he goes I
don't know who told you Medela was bad
that's one of the Mexico's best [ __ ]
brands of beer and that's what we export
that's not quite what I think they meant
at the [ __ ] liquor store what they
meant was is that it was kind of like
artificially flavored and it's just kind
of mass produced it's not craft
but [ __ ] that man it was a good drinking
experience yeah it wasn't cheap it was
like three something a [ __ ] can which
that's kind of an expensive can yeah it
was like 350 again
but uh it was a good drinking experience
and yeah they were all good that was an
experience that 200 years ago you'd
given that to a dam
drink connoisseur and you didn't show
them they came out of a can he'd be like
oh it's magnificent
fantastic you know like my new feet yeah
[ __ ] it's been like that you know
what I mean it's all perception it's all
perception
I try to kind of like keep that
perspective yeah it's perception because
I'm just kind of like like I said I'm
not a big booze connoisseur I know what
I like I've liked but I don't you know I
haven't drunk like there's millions of
things I haven't drunk so some things I
might like better
so sometimes I like really cheap [ __ ]
sometimes I like expensive [ __ ] it's
just like whatever and I've had really
expensive [ __ ] that I didn't like too
there are certain things where you don't
want to [ __ ] there are certain things
you don't want to cheap out on sure
like if you're into single malt scotch
whiskeys
but you're looking for a particular
thing when you're doing that you know
you're looking for a particular drink
experience you're gonna pay for that you
know what I mean you're not gonna be
able to replicate
glad fitted Scotch you're just not
you're gonna have to buy glitter fitting
that's the wrong thing that's the wrong
thing you know what I mean so
it's not across the board type of [ __ ]
that cheap [ __ ] replaces expensive [ __ ]
no that's not what I'm saying I'm just
what I'm saying is just because it's
inexpensive doesn't mean it's bad
there's certain [ __ ] drink
experiences out there don't cost much
they're [ __ ] good they're good I'm
gonna say in this this not only applies
to alcohol but applies to pretty much
everything
up to a certain price point
you get what you pay for your
diminishing returns under a certain
price point like okay for example back
in the old days we used to get an eye
bar
and the what was the well liquor that
they used what was the name of that [ __ ]
there's a bunch of different ones I
can't remember the brand the whiskey or
the all of it the like the brand that
they yeah but she was terrible
Aristocrat Aristocrat Aristocrat that
was the brand that they used yeah okay I
will admit with my limited booze
experience that [ __ ] was terrible a risk
aristot was bad it tasted like yeah it
tasted like rubbing alcohol yeah okay so
that was their well alcohol so you knew
about you knew better than to get that
you had to be sloshed before you could
drink a restaurant yeah if you were
really [ __ ] up then okay it's fine
like it's way cheaper okay I get it but
after like once you get to like the
second or third tier up from that
there's not a hell of a lot of
difference like for me there's not a big
difference between Chivas Regal and
Chivas Royale chose Royale is a lot more
expensive if she was Regal it's the same
brand
I really I don't well I've never I've
never noticed a particular difference
between for example
Sam's yeah uh vodka like what is it
called American Something art Sams yeah
I don't know it's just called Sam's
[ __ ] Sam's vodka America whatever
it's basically that Gray Goose yes it
honestly the difference between that and
Sky yeah which is like twice the price
yeah I can't tell the difference William
it can't tell the difference it might be
the same there's a lot I suspect there's
a lot it's the same I can't tell the
difference I think it's Gray Goose
which Gray Goose is like the good [ __ ]
yeah I think it's Gray Goose it tastes
like Gray's Goose to me
and it might even come out of the same
Distillery because some of its brand
naming and packaging and well yeah yeah
and stuff but it tastes like Gray Goose
to me
yeah I've never really noticed the
difference like if we go it's high
quality we don't go to Sam's as often
because it's farther away now it's much
cheaper to buy liquor at Sam's uh and
they're vodka and uh you know their
tequila is actually really good their
vodka is what like 13.99 for a big
[ __ ] bottle
yeah so if you bought that same size
bottle in for example Sky it would be
like twice the price because the Sky
Vodka is what like 22.99 something like
that and the one at Sam's is I think
it's 13.99 that's what it was last time
I bought it and I honestly cannot tell
the difference now if you go like lower
than that like I said you go to like
Evan Williams or Aristocrat or something
like that then I can tell the difference
but other than that I can't tell the
difference that's Sam's Silver Tequila
okay it comes with a cork how much is
that nice bottle that's about I think of
12 I think for that big old thing
and I can't tell this
from Milagro silver
and according to Khan
he said Milagro
is the best brand you can buy in Mexico
I said Milagro's smoothness like that
[ __ ] I don't know real good smooth
silver can't tequila great in a mixed
drink
they don't have a Reposado or uh or a
gold you know they don't have it but
they just have a silver yeah they don't
have a lot to pick from but what they do
have is not other than their whiskey
their whiskey sucks but other than that
terrible I'm just gonna say yeah their
whiskey like I said tastes like licking
an old barbecue grill that you haven't
cleaned in a while
it's very very burned tasting but uh
other than that like every other uh
spirit every other liquor that I've got
from there has actually been really good
other than the whiskey which is terrible
um set seed says I like your blue hair
on point thank you very much
Modelo is okay says Victor
yeah
try this
I yeah I actually really likes those
that Modelo
Modelo it was like a double-sized mango
habanero michelada I think it was
habanero it was yeah I did it in a
[ __ ] salted glass with a salted rim
with ice in it and poured it in there
man that [ __ ] was good
got a whole video
and the pineapple was good and so was
the Naranja
the orange I think the pineapple is my
favorite
they were all good but they were all
good and I don't even like mango and the
mango was like pretty much yeah the mega
habanero I think it was real good I
think that was it Chipotle
oh now I might have been mango Chipotle
or mango habanero I didn't see them
today it was good it had some heat to it
no I got that at the red next door
I mean I'm sure they had it at ABC I
just was we were I looked for it didn't
see it oh really okay
Victor says I can only drink about two
of those uh they get me full quick which
ones yeah
if you guys don't know what a michelada
is
you can see recipes online
think of you're out on a street party
everybody's [ __ ] drunk
you want a mixed drink
but you maybe you don't have the money
for [ __ ] hard liquor or maybe it's
too hot outside for hard liquor so you
make a mixed drink out of beer
had a cheaper beer
and you pour it over ice and put
flavoring in it and spices in it and
salt the rim
you think that's [ __ ] crazy oh no
it's [ __ ] great man [ __ ] it's
called a michelada
some Micheladas are based in tomatoes
some some Micheladas are based in
um fruit don't they make someone with
Clamato yeah like tomato and clams yeah
it's a tomato yeah
and uh and then they'll put some [ __ ]
Spice in there some kind of chili for
The Salted rim and it's hot out and
you're [ __ ] dancing and you're
drinking that and you've got girls
everywhere it's like that that's that's
what that's the world that that comes
from you're drinking lots of oh no that
was a reality when I lived in Brazil
that was a reality that was like [ __ ]
back there in carnival that's what
that's kind of [ __ ] you'd drink during
Carnival
because uh you could drink a lot of them
Charlie Huck says hi from Argentina
love tonight's show how you doing do you
remember you know all about Carnival
they don't have it in Argentina but you
probably [ __ ] went up there
picture says it's kind of like a bloody
mary made with beer yeah yeah but they
have fruit flavors yeah the ones we got
were from we have our food fruit with
spice
yeah
I love Bloody Mary's though
every now and then we make like I said
they give me a really bad heartburn but
I love [ __ ] Bloody Mary I don't think
I ever went to Argentina
you went to Chile though you went to
Chile and went to much of a deal I think
that's Uruguay or Paraguay
I don't think I ever went to our to to
Target I heard Argentina had a damn bad
economic collapse about 10 years ago I
don't know what this what's going on now
maybe it's recovered
I don't know have a chat I gotta go to
the bathroom
probably I should get another drink too
that's only my what second or third one
yeah just pour some right here get them
right here
in Brazil
here in the United States Brazilian
Brazilian women have a reputation for
being very good looking very Charming
in Brazil Argentine women had a had a
reputation of being Charmed so this is
just this is kind of
kind of goes around in a circle
foreign
I'm coming back with some ice
put this in Jenny's drink
give her some ice too
there you go
yeah I'll put some ice in the drinks
I heard it crash what happened well
nothing crashed what crashed oh no no no
just what crashed I don't know I heard
it crash no no I was just putting the
thing back in the ice
she thinks she's thinking things crashed
the bathroom looks like
no no oh my God he fell over or
something no no no no
no did you really like take off and like
just leave no no no I'm talking no of
course not yeah you did because I came
out of the bathroom
you're right here
Pookie is like in her she's in the cat
tree like right outside my office like
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
poor Pokey no I have fun in Chile Chile
was [ __ ] great back in the day
Victor says Argentina is always having
an economy yes I think you can't deal
with money you can't give it and Victor
says Chile is on my bucket list I'm an
earthquake Chaser yeah
I've never been to Chile but no yeah I
was in Santiago
it was beautiful
it's like something out of James Bond
well then they filmed some James Bond
[ __ ] there
I'll probably hold on
all those people are good looking down
Tammy said yes Tom abandoned us that's
what I thought I came out of the
bathroom seriously I go to the bathroom
it's like less than two minutes he can't
even stay here for less than two minutes
oh my God I can't even deal I can't deal
I have to like sit here and talk while
he goes to the bathroom and like wanders
around the house for like
five ten minutes at a time but he can't
even sit here for two minutes while I go
to the bathroom but you know whatever
whatever
cause I came out and he was like running
around
I don't know
uh yeah I know I'm like I'm so hungry
you guys it's like
this [ __ ] diet man it's killing but
it's not his diet I'm just trying to
like not
all I've eaten today I ate for breakfast
I had
a cup of coffee
and I had two of those little
what are the cuties like oranges
tangerines what the [ __ ] are those I
don't know those I had two of those for
breakfast
for lunch I had a chicken salad sandwich
and a couple crackers
that's it
and the and the liquor that's all I've
had today
in a row 20 miles on a bike today
so there's that
Louis says good afternoon everyone late
to the show again that's okay that's
okay we're just hanging out getting
drunk on moonshine we haven't even like
busted open the rum that we got yet I
told him I'm like because look I don't
have a lot of money he doesn't have a
lot of money
so I was like we're gonna get the
Moonshine and that's just really
expensive they were legit almost 20 per
jar and we got two of them so I was like
well that's [ __ ] forty dollars right
there
so I was like well we were almost out of
vodka and we were always out of rum and
I was like well let's get something
cheap that we can mix with things that
we already have like because we already
have orange juice we already have
there's some kind of like tropical juice
Blend or something like that that we
have in there so I was like I want to
get something cheap that we can mix with
that so I don't have to just like drink
the Moonshine because that's gonna be
you know that's we gotta sip that slow
because it's very expensive
so we got this and it was on sale
I think it was like this was 11.99 like
normally I think this was 14.99 or
something
and I was like I don't even think I
tried this brand before but they had it
on sale for 11.99 and I was like man
they can't be that bad
I mean you know
it was only one or two shelves down from
like the good [ __ ] so
we'll see how it goes we haven't even
like busted that open yet
so I was like well I'm gonna pay money I
want something that's like and you know
what's weird the lady the girl that
works at the ABC
she remembered us from last week
like last week we went in there and I
guess we mentioned when we were checking
out because we were buying all the
pumpkin spice stuff and uh I think Tom
had like his podcast shirt on or
something like that and he's like yeah
we're buying this stuff to like taste
test on our show and she remembered that
from last week so she came in today and
I was buying the stuff she's like oh you
taste testing stuff again because I was
buying the butter butter pecan like uh
you know moonshine and I was like yeah
she's like have that last step work out
so I was like wow so it's like she
remembered
did you see that because you wanted to
well you went to a different
um checkout yeah the girl from last week
remembered us oh did it and asked she's
like oh had that last taste test work
out okay because she remembered all the
all the pumpkins spiced okay
so I was kind of like
seriously though okay let's talk about
this for a second okay I'm not [ __ ]
on old dudes
she's [ __ ] on old dudes
I'm not I just said I wasn't you just
prefaced this [ __ ] like I'm not [ __ ]
on an old dude
go ahead but well I'm just saying I have
experience with this too yeah so the old
dude I was behind in line was like
talking to the girl that I eventually
checked out with yeah
old dudes I guess they're lonely I'm not
[ __ ] on them like I said because I
guess they're lonely but they go out to
the liquor store Louie's here do you say
hallelujah what's up okay yeah what's up
Louie yeah he said ever later yeah it's
fine I mean you did miss a lot but yeah
it's okay
we we were just talking about [ __ ]
and Sebastian said we talk about food
and booze like yeah Sebastian I don't
know you said we're facing an electronic
collapse I don't know who we are I don't
know what country you're in okay go
ahead
like what else is new oh you gotta
preface the [ __ ] like look we're heading
towards a global me I'm always facing it
I've been facing an economic collapse
since I was a child yeah so I'm kind of
like used to it so no the whole [ __ ]
Western world's [ __ ] up uh it's gonna
y'all need to Buck Up be strong let's do
it be strong and [ __ ] used to it this
is like be strong no different than what
I've it might be bad we'll see we'll see
it might get bad but uh
do what you can to [ __ ] cover your
ass
just saying yeah as much as you can well
like I said it's like I'm kind of used
to it right so
because I've been pouring my home away
so I'm not worried about it so um but
yeah so she so he was in front of me in
line like there were two lines open
because it's Friday so everybody's in
there like buying booze
so Tom goes to the other line and I'm
still waiting because I was like well
I'll buy half of the [ __ ] you buy half
of this [ __ ] we did a whole thing
so I'm waiting behind this old dude and
I said to myself like this old dude is
just talking about Grand Marnier to this
girl and nobody cares about Grandma and
you like for ages and I'm just kind of
like and he keeps looking back at me
like oh there's somebody waiting I'm
like yeah somebody's waiting that's how
life works so maybe you should move it
along some old people want to be the
center of attention well see that's what
and that reminded me because I used to
work in a print shop
and we used to have there was like two
or three old guys
and they would come in and just get like
some [ __ ] like one thing printed or
some [ __ ] like that and then they would
be in there for like half an hour or
like an hour like talking about whatever
and well that was theirs that's what I
mean and they'd be talking about like
politics I'm just like and I'm sitting
there going that's their internet
and I'm just sitting there going oh my
God please kill me and it's just like
this is why I can't stand working in
customer service because like look I
don't want to have to stand there for
half an hour an hour and listen to you
[ __ ] about whatever the [ __ ] you
care about because I don't care about it
and I have to be nice to you or I'm
gonna get fired and that's not cool yeah
so the fact that I have to stand there
and like listen to whatever crap you're
talking about it's like really and I had
that a couple times like when I worked
to The Print Shop like these crazy old
dudes would come in and be like these
kids today with their abortions and blah
blah and I'm just like oh Jesus Christ
please that's there that's their energy
please kill me and it's just like please
find something better to do get a dog
dog or something that you can talk to
please don't come here and talk to me
because I don't want to hear it it's
like you know
it's just hopefully that's been going on
forever I know it's like I just really
really don't want my grandmother when
I'm old my grandmother died [ __ ] man my
grandmother died
worried about [ __ ] that was like I
laughed at
you know what I mean and her concerns
what she was concerned about was just
like
just crazy out of date [ __ ] and that's
just the way it is but the thing is is
that that was them
that was another generation undergoing a
[ __ ] massive transition that we went
through
we even transitioned into the internet
okay
we don't age the way they do it's very
different now you know I mean Gen X is
not growing old the same way as Boomers
grew old and then the [ __ ]
pre-boomers what did you call those
dudes like my grandmother she wasn't
even a boomer she was before that I
don't know what you call that a caveman
they were cave man certain things that
they knew were right but they were very
very basic outside that
they worried about things that weren't
worrying worryable
you know
my grandmother didn't believe me when I
said that
that in that I went to University and
Mission Michigan to go visit my friend
Steve
all right and that the dharms there were
co-ed
that each [ __ ] apartment was male
female
she lost her [ __ ] behind that
oh no that can't be that can't be right
so no no yeah oh well who would send
their
who would send their children to a
university
yeah yeah and I was just looking there
was like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about what planet are you from you're
right
so you have to understand that
not all the boomers are [ __ ] up not
all of them but
most of them are [ __ ] up
but their parents were even more [ __ ]
up
all right they're all dead now okay and
and they have no idea what was going on
my grandmother would think what was
happening right now was hell
all right that there's no way that this
is possible
you know
uh but
we don't really have to worry about that
because we're changing along with
everybody else
we're in the same we're in the same
Medium as other people she had I don't
think she I think when she died I don't
think she knew anything about internet
well my grandma did yeah yeah like she
saw us using it like in the 90s and
stuff but yeah she was afraid of it and
didn't get it like we'd be like look you
can do this and that and the other she's
like
yeah right
and uh what was funny is that as
resistant as they were
to reality
they were also pretty kind they were
kind of beta they were very followers
they had to be told what to do
um they weren't as independent as people
think
they were very much uh into the
hierarchy and very much into having
um elected leaders telling them how to
think and and what to do they would
never [ __ ] accept what they're being
told to do now you know or and what to
think now so they would think that they
were in hell
but
so they weren't
you know I'm kind of like on the I'm
kind of like I wouldn't call myself a
conservative at all I'm not very
conservative but I'm traditionalist
I don't know if that because I don't
think I don't think conservatives can
serve anything I think that's a [ __ ]
lame term
oh but I am like kind of like on on the
right I would say but then how you
define that I think a lot of what they
do is on is full of [ __ ]
two
um
some people would say that yeah well I
don't know exactly what I was getting at
this you forgot yeah the um
the older Generations [ __ ] uh didn't
really understand anything they were
very low information they weren't dumb
it's just they didn't have all the
information so it kind of [ __ ] skewed
their opinions on things
they would see a goth and their minds
would go [ __ ] crazy and just read
into some [ __ ] like that like that that
mess well I remember when it was just
happened that doesn't [ __ ] really
mean that what you think it is they were
like they were difficult to deal with
well you tried to explain it to them
like it's like look I just like the
Aesthetics I like music and stuff like
that and they really didn't they
couldn't understand that they're like no
it must have some greater meaning you
must be like into Satanism or something
like really no you must be a communist
you must be on this and that I'm like
really no man
when I got out of the army and moved
[ __ ] Boston
I started hanging out one of the coolest
golf clubs it was called [ __ ] in in
the United States at the time it was
called man rays and Man Ray was like the
bat cave all right it was like the bat
cave of [ __ ] Boston
some people that would go to the [ __ ]
bat cave and that [ __ ] kind of dwindled
down during the 90s but some of the
people from the from the New York scene
would come to our scene and go man this
is [ __ ] awesome
Symphony went loved it she says no this
is the [ __ ] best club we've seen in
the nation she would she tour through
there
ah
on the surface
like my grandmother would probably think
yeah these are all a bunch of [ __ ]
Communists or crazy but
it's not the way it was my best buddy it
was just a thing of the time his name
was Vadim kanyev all right and he was a
Russian infantry veteran who'd survived
the [ __ ] collapse of the Soviet Union
and I was an American Veteran who'd
[ __ ] went through all that [ __ ] of
the 90s and he was goth as [ __ ] and I
was goth as [ __ ] and we were hanging out
in the club scene I showed Jenny
pictures of him goes man he's cute he
looked like a [ __ ] Antonio Banderas
big long [ __ ] black hair and he was
into computers
and you would I would call him a [ __ ]
like a hardcore Russian dude he would be
a kind of like a [ __ ] militant
con
traditionalist Russian
old school you know what I mean [ __ ]
you'd call him on the right but [ __ ]
we dated girls that would be on the left
[ __ ] we got along with him he had a
[ __ ] computer shop
in a three-story house that he owned at
that time and every floor had hooked not
hookers had strippers living on it they
were almost the same thing they were
almost the same thing and [ __ ] he had
all these [ __ ] strippers living with
him and [ __ ] his girlfriend was a
stripper and then he broke up with her
but she'd hang out with him anyway she
was cool too Boston stripper and and
they were all these guys stripper fetish
girls and [ __ ] and we just had a good
time man in the club scene
and
somebody like an old school generation
would never really understand that hey
now we're actually kind of like the
traditionalists you know
[ __ ] they're around they they judge
people by how they dressed all right and
we got along back then if you ask me
look if you really look at this Left
Right Paradigm which in the American
system I think is [ __ ] [ __ ]
because the two-party system is all
[ __ ] fake
they're all loyal to the [ __ ]
bureaucrats and [ __ ] oligarchs
but the energies behind left and right
actually need each other for survival
because they're like two sides of the
same coin they really should be working
together
uh right now the [ __ ] divisions are
[ __ ] bad you know and it's it's uh
I don't know how it's gonna work out but
it's not gonna work out good I don't
think but back in the day
people got along all right
you weren't at each other's throats like
that you know it was kind of like male
and female positive negative
yin and yang and dark and light you had
to have it one side kind of complimented
the other there are certain things that
the [ __ ] left is right about there
are certain things that the right is
right about there's a lot that both
sides are right are wrong about you know
I mean nobody's right about everything
it's a it's kind of like a what do you
call it
it's a it's a spectrum
everything kind of has to be kind of
every time everything it's a spectrum
that's really how you should approach
everything right that's why I really
don't like
ever since I was born pretty much or
ever since I can remember I do not like
any kind of hierarchical authoritarian I
don't like anything like that anybody
telling me what to do how to live what
to do like any of that stuff I don't
like it well it depends on the situation
I don't like that stuff now some stuff
it depends on the situation well yeah if
you're in the kitchen the [ __ ] head
chef is in charge that's what I'm saying
you if you are at War the military
[ __ ] experts who [ __ ] have [ __ ]
military experience that have killed
people and [ __ ] been through this
[ __ ] they are in charge so yeah but
there has to be hierarchy but it's
situational it's Mission oriented that's
what I mean when there's no point to it
yeah I don't really understand being
told what to do or how to like live my
life or anything like that I was kind of
laughing at grandpar saying us old guys
love pestering the poor Girls behind the
counter please don't do that yeah don't
do this damn girls alone um we think
they dig us but actually we're a pain in
it you are yes we are opinion they're
digging honestly there's digging some
dude that's one-third your age and she
on on her [ __ ] well look I worked in
a [ __ ] record store in the mall and
sometimes you'd get like some old
[ __ ] coming in there because old
dude and I worked at a print shop like
old dudes come in they're lonely I get
it but they come in and this is their
social interaction for the day
and I'm like you gotta impose that on me
me and my ass is like look I don't give
a [ __ ] about how lonely you are I don't
give a [ __ ] about it so I don't like to
talk to people I don't like to deal with
people I just want to paycheck and I
want to go home you know what I mean so
don't come in here and like [ __ ]
Regale me with you it's just tiresome
the whole time you're talking I'm gonna
be like please shut up please shut up
please shut up please shut up I'm gonna
be like that so I'm just telling you and
probably most people are the same yeah
so I'm just like please shut up please
shut up so please don't do that please
don't do that so retail workers they
don't make enough money to pull like put
up with that [ __ ] I'm just saying
um John Gore says I always just listen
to the old people talk to the cashier
it's the mundane pattern that makes up
reality it can be very Illuminating well
it's fun to an extent but when I'm just
waiting to like check out my [ __ ]
liquor I'm like dude shut up nobody
cares just get out yeah I don't I don't
mean to be that person I'm old too but
you know
granther says that generation talked
about the older generation looked at
God's minorities and anyone who didn't
look like them with great judgment and
suspicion I remember that
honestly I kind of feel like I didn't
even look that weird back in the day by
today's standards
by today's standards you can walk around
no one would even like look twice at you
but back then
man
I was just like at school people thought
it was a Satanist you'd go in a store
and like dudes be following you around
think you were like stealing [ __ ] and
stuff like that like back in the 80s
Jesus Christ it was a yeah yeah it was
the whole thing I guess I just lived in
a good time I got to see a little bit of
everything Grandpa's was there [ __ ]
we grew up together for a certain period
we we had a good time grathers we got to
see a good
well good a good a good [ __ ] variety
of [ __ ] things because the world was
changing during our whole lives that's
what I mean I kind of I don't love that
stuck in anything well yeah and honestly
it's like it's not cool it's not awesome
being old I'm not saying that like I
don't love being old but
I do like that we grew up like on the
cusp of
no internet and all this kind of thing
we've had internet yeah we know so we
kind of like are right in between those
things so we kind of like had
feet in both camps yeah and I really
like how that worked out because we
understand what the world was like
before yeah and we understand what the
world was like after so I kind of feel
like that gives us like a a little bit
of a unique perspective actually
I [ __ ] grew up
in my early year years in a Christian
Military Academy in California very
anti-communist okay
and then later on in the service and
then after that in the goth scene
hanging out with a dude that was just
like me from a [ __ ] Russian infantry
unit it was it was ex-communist and
[ __ ] weird having a [ __ ] he was like
my best buddy during that time and we
were [ __ ] scooping up on all these
girls back in those days [ __ ] Jenny
saw him he was [ __ ] we were [ __ ]
cute back in those days
and uh Superstars
and it was great and he'd tell me
everything about the Communist system
and how [ __ ] ridiculous it was that
you couldn't get how restrictive
everything was that you couldn't get
anything done and uh how how limited
[ __ ] was
um it was like being in the Army but
even when you were a civilian you were
like in the Army everything was run with
or they tried to run everything with
military Precision including the
civilian economy man that's a huge task
you can't get that done you got to give
people the freedom to [ __ ]
run their own business you know I mean
or to [ __ ] manage a company and
disseminate product everything was about
paperwork and just the bureaucracy from
what he said was just [ __ ]
bureaucracy [ __ ] just choked
everything down
and it was just like meaningless
bureaucracy it was fake
and just meeting that dude and it was
funny because it was like the cold war
was over
and you realize that
they were like us in many ways many ways
in some ways they were better they were
tougher
Vadim was kind of like somebody to come
out of a damn Maximum Security Prison in
some ways or a military unit was like a
weird mixture of stuff and he was
imagine a dude that had come out of a
Maximum Security Prison and a whole
bunch of [ __ ] hardship and strength
but then he had all this education he
was super educated knew everything about
the Arts knew everything about [ __ ]
Russian history and their literature and
everything he was just you know and he
didn't have a college degree it's just
that's the way they were they were they
were far more knowledgeable than people
think they were they were squared away
and then they were kind of like he was
kind of like
um
he could self he could criticize the
system he was critical about it critical
analysis you know
uh and he likes the Western system
better he just said just a more
naturalistic just kind of let it happen
by Nature you can't control it
um
but we'll see you know he's in Germany
now I haven't talked to him in a like I
said a few months I mean I kind of
consider myself a leftist or Progressive
or whatever you want to call it but
I like to think that I don't really have
I don't have any kind of like cultist
allegiance to anything so I like to see
things as objectively as possible I'm a
very scientifically minded person
so the problem with progressivism is
this you can progress until you get it
right once it's right you can't progress
out of that it's right just leave it and
a lot of progressives will get it right
and then they try to progress outside
that and now it no longer works yeah but
that's a word and you're getting hung up
on that what
you're getting hung up on that word what
what word Progressive
I'm just I'm just gonna go back and say
what I said before some progressives
will get something right and then try to
progress outside of that and now it's
not right anymore
you know if I can once it's right leave
it alone once the society Works leave it
alone
so I can just let it work
because some things are right
you know there's no reason to change
something that's already working this
fix don't burn this is a it's a military
[ __ ] the military does the same thing
you know what I mean [ __ ] don't if
it's not broken don't fix it you know
[ __ ] if you try to fix something that's
already working then you're just gonna
[ __ ] it up
because it's an analog system it's not
it's not
it's not digital and it's also reality
isn't moral it's more practical than
anything else uh yeah you can try to
inject some fairness into it
but then there's going to be a bunch of
bunch of [ __ ] disagreements about
what's fair
as long as everybody's making money and
everybody's happy then it's working
that's that's how it goes they can't get
much better than that Victor said we
need to get rid of lobbying and put term
limits and age limits in for congress I
agree with that yeah too much corruption
in there this [ __ ] show up
without a pot to piss in and Tiffany
yeah and then you look at that they
showed up with no money and now they're
billionaires you're going to tell me
that they're honest no
not at all they're [ __ ] taking
kickbacks from huge corporations so
they're not working for us they're
working for them they're working for
those [ __ ] corporations and those
little oligarchs but that's been going
on forever yeah but that's not good well
no it's not good I'm just saying it's
been going on forever and just the
longer it goes on the worse it gets
so something's got to be done about it
Zach says uh Zach got a job all right so
Jackie Zach decided he was going to get
a job no he got a job he well he was
messaging me about it earlier like he
asked me if I had any advice because it
was at a print shop I was like dude I
think the last time I worked at a print
shop was like 10 years ago yeah I don't
and I've never been good at interviews
so I don't like you know what to say but
he says I'm super excited for my print
shop job what was yours like Jen the
place I'll be working at seems cool as
all hell I hope it is
um okay I worked at one place in Tampa
that all I remember about it was like
the dude that owned it was a was like
the world's biggest who's that
[ __ ] that did um
that [ __ ]
yeah what's all that Key West [ __ ]
if you like paint no it's not that
what the [ __ ] was that it was
I'll remember in a second but he liked
all that kind of music you'll remember
yeah and uh yeah he played that [ __ ]
CD over and over and I wasn't into that
I worked there a month and then like I
took off but when I moved to Orlando
initially I got a job at a print shop in
Oviedo
and it was actually owned by a gay
couple and they were actually like
really really cool like I actually like
made I was like really good friends with
them and like you know that was like a
cool job I liked that a lot
um what grandpa said that Steve is
coming over to [ __ ] build his first
AR do you have the little [ __ ]
plastic Jigs and the vice I got all that
and then uh Victor Garcia says that
[ __ ] the Boomers were fighting
Fascism and now they're begging the fort
here at home what it is is it's kind of
yeah corporations have [ __ ] taken
over and they [ __ ]
they own the media and they own both
parties most of both parties if you
believe anything outside that normal
[ __ ] Republican Democrat Paradigm and
that's the Paradigm that they want
because they can control that then
they're going to call you a racist and a
fascist and a threat to democracy but
that's all lies what it is is that you
are a threat to their oligarchy and
their money that's what it is
and what they do is to to survive is
that they divide the people they're
trying to divide the people to keep them
fighting against one another that's how
they keep themselves in power and that's
been going on for hundreds of years the
British actually invented that [ __ ] back
in India back in the Imperial age do you
divide a population and get them to
fight one another so you can stay in
power
that's all it is this is an oligarchy
all right it's not a democracy it's a
[ __ ] it's an illusion of a democracy
they want you to vote for candidates
that they control if they don't control
them they don't want you voting for them
that's all it is
and they don't give a [ __ ] about us
they don't give a [ __ ] about us they
only care about their power and their
money they don't live here all right
they got islands and [ __ ] but Florida's
underage sex girls and [ __ ] that all
[ __ ] proven all right they make a
[ __ ] ton of money
it can't go on forever
it's coming to a head the Earth the
world is changing
there must be a true Democratic process
people have to follow laws
they are above the law and that you
can't do that okay it'll start to become
an anarcho-tyranny like Brazil and I was
in there and I know exactly what that's
like
and that's kind of what we have it's an
anarcho tyranny with the illusion of a
democratic process
they want they want elections but they
want rigged elections with candidates
that they own that's all it is
not me saying this and it's not this is
not something new this has been going on
for a long time
another lying about it
I remember [ __ ] six seven years ago
University of Notre Dame came out with a
[ __ ] study saying they tracked
what what this what this the house and
the Senate does and the bills and
everything and they tracked everything
and they found out that really they pass
everything that they pass
only
really own is only advantageous to them
in the ruling class none of it has
anything to do with the people is that
it's not a true Democratic Republic it's
it's like a it's an oligarchy
you know and we just have to start
accepting it for what it is
the highest form of organized crime
and a lot of it has to do with what
[ __ ] General Eisenhower warned about
it's a bureaucracy
and behind that bureaucracy is the
[ __ ] military-industrial complex that
that Eisenhower worried about as long as
we're at War they're making money
they want these fake Wars
and I fought in [ __ ] one of them
but they lied to us about what it was it
takes time to figure out it's they can't
the internet has [ __ ] pulled the wall
over has pulled the [ __ ] Veil
slowly people are starting to realize
what this is
I think I'm gonna reassure you people
this is a dangerous time I'm gonna
reassure you I think America will be
reborn
it's going to take time it's gonna be
hard
but eventually this [ __ ] will stop
we just got to get rid of them just got
to vote him out of office you just gotta
everybody's got to start talking about
what this is so they can't hide
and then once that happens these Wars
Will Stop
and this quest for being a unipolar
[ __ ] superpower
and trying to wage Ward anything that
threatens us
there are other countries there are
other civilizations in here we can't
tell people how to live we're not the
World Police that's a [ __ ] fantastic
movie with the little puppets what was
the name of that what was the name of
that one with the little puppet so it's
kind of like the Thunderbirds the [ __ ]
was funny as [ __ ] something or other
what are you talking about it was that
funny [ __ ] program it's called
Thunderbird World Police South Park yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] something other World
Police where [ __ ] they got America
going around trying to stop all the
other nations from being what they're
from what being what they are and she
was [ __ ] hilarious but that's what
they want because they make money on it
it's about money
I'm gonna uh you want some more ice
yeah right oh I'm [ __ ] loaded man
this uh Team America World Team America
World Police that [ __ ] that's what it is
that's what it is because Team America
World Police makes a lot of money for
them
uh we'll get some ice this [ __ ] this
moonshine is [ __ ] slamming
I mean it better be it was Nineteen
dollars
for that jar
nineteen dollars
it's good though it's good
picture says the internet has also made
a large percentage of Americans into
batshit crazy conspiracy theorists
yep I I see that happening
ledge sword it's a double-edged sword I
wouldn't go back to the old days before
we had the internet but
the internet's made a lot of things
easier and it's also made
um it easier to disseminate [ __ ]
so
you know double-edged sword like I said
I wouldn't want to go back
but there's always side effects always
sometimes yeah but if you look deep
enough Hugo says also I think the 80s
were one of the best decades because
young people today still love the 80s
era I mean so it was so optimistic it
was a time of optimism
that's the thing like look I lived like
both of us yeah I was a teenager I
graduated from high school in 1990. so
my formative years were the 80s as were
yours yeah
would I want to go back to the 80s no no
no no
um there was some cool [ __ ] back then
not saying that it's because the 70s
were over that's what that's why the 80s
were so good I kind of feel like that
might have been yeah yeah there was a
lot of cool [ __ ] about the 80s but there
was a lot of really lame [ __ ] about
communities too because honestly like
like I said me and him we grew up in the
80s we were in high school in the 80s uh
junior high school and 80s we were
looking forward everything seemed to be
possible in the 80s although it just let
me let me cat let me give that a little
bit of a caveat because the 90s blue I
liked them a did them I liked them I
liked them aided the 90s I guess I guess
that's a person once I graduated I
graduated from high school in 1990.
and once
honestly like I don't know and maybe
this is kind of like coming from a the
perspective of somebody that is that was
kind of like into more like the
underground kind of stuff
so I graduated from high school in 1990
1991 uh was the year that punk broke
where you know Nirvana's never mind was
like a huge thing everybody like
discovered Underground Music suddenly
and so everybody got back in all this
80s stuff and suddenly my life became
not as good anymore because everyone's
like oh now I love the Pixies and I'm
like yeah well I've liked the Pixies for
many years but it was like a hipster
thing
so after that happened
um I don't know I kind of feel like
everything went like it got
commercialized like everything that had
been cool about the 80s
was
commodified I don't know I didn't quite
see it that put into well that's what it
seemed like to me because it kind of
seemed like after Tim Burton kind of
came out and like after all that kind of
stuff came out then suddenly like the
mainstream was like oh my God like we
love all this like goth type stuff but
like not
I don't know like it wasn't the same and
I don't know it just it just kind of
like bummed me out I didn't really like
the 90s yeah there was some good movies
that came out then there was the good
music that came out then but it's like
it wasn't the same it wasn't the same
I can't really like put my finger on it
but it wasn't the same like after the
90s came in
and a lot of the trends of the 90s
even now like now that I'm old and I
like look back on like the trends of the
90s and stuff I'm like man that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] that was lame
I would never like defend any of the
trends that came out in the 90s because
I didn't like even like it back then
even back then I was just kind of like
man this decade blows I don't like it
honestly I like like the later decades
more than I like the 90s I don't like
the 90s yeah Victor I want to recommend
a channel to you
here on YouTube
look for a channel name is Garland
Nixon
he's an ex-c cop ex-police investigator
who's way into this topic that we're
talking about with the [ __ ] uh the
military industrial complex deep State
geopolitics he's an ex-police
investigator
African-American dude [ __ ] genius all
right
and when you listen to [ __ ] Garland
that he's he's right he's right he's got
the military police
background the knowledge of [ __ ]
bureaucracies and how systems work
and and how
centralized governments work he has the
[ __ ] historical knowledge of
[ __ ] a genius he's just unsung
genius Garland
his name is Garland Nixon go check him
out and he's real good he doesn't have a
whole lot of followers
but he's just he's been guests on a
bunch of shows but he he whatever he
says just picture me going yep yep
exactly yep exactly that's my experience
also yes exactly they're not intelligent
they're dumb the people that are running
this
they're uh I'm gonna let him I'm not
gonna [ __ ] put words in his mouth
you'll see
they're just kind of going
based upon what they're told to do it's
a [ __ ] system and uh and it's failing
it's failing it's time to reboot it's
one thing that I can change one thing
that I realized what fairly early yeah
when I was young
was that
I realized that most of the people
running the world were Dumber they're
dumb me yeah and I was just like wow
that's alarming they're dumb
they're they're dumb and they're doing
what they're told to do and uh they're
uh they're just trying to get through
the day and there's a pattern to that
system and uh Garland Nixon listen to
what he says he'll leave he's even
talking about Ukraine and what's
happening there and where the money's
going and why they're doing what they're
doing and what the end result will be
and he'll use historical [ __ ] data
he's he's got training of a [ __ ] real
investigative [ __ ] reporter and he's
just doing what an investigative
reporter and another era would have done
but they're all paid off now they're
corporate corporations just pay him to
say put out propaganda really is what
they're doing
Zach said as much as I love the internet
I feel like it's damaged people's
ability to communicate interpersonally
in some ways especially young people
well I don't know because the thing
about it is that I mean I grew up before
there was an internet and before there
was an internet I was not a big fan of
like communicating with with people
interpersonally so oh I can give
examples it wasn't it wasn't really a
thing for me so honestly when email came
along when all that kind of like stuff I
was like oh my God hallelujah like I can
actually like communicate with people in
the way that I would prefer to
communicate communicate with people
which was in writing I'm not really big
um on communicating with people in
person I feel like I don't come across
in person the same way that I would
ideally like to come across with people
so I'd like to like be able to like
think about what I'm gonna say so I like
to kind of like write stuff you know
what I mean so the fact that now
everybody is communicating like that
that was like a Big Boon for me I feel
like and I don't I feel like I'm maybe
not the only person I can mitigate I
understand what you're saying but I'm
gonna mitigate that a little bit
Jenny and I in our [ __ ] work in the
clubs and hanging out in clubs we can
come we run across couples that are the
guys in his early 20s the girls in their
late teens
and yeah when they show up they are a
little awkward
because they've been doing a lot of
online stuff they're new to face-to-face
negotiations and socializing
but when you really start [ __ ] with
them and hitting them hard and [ __ ] and
like look that's what you did they they
come up to Snuff quite quickly
uh
it's just because very young people
who are not really used to a club scene
and dealing with people face to face
have a lot of inhibitions that come from
the online culture
you can get them to break that mold
quickly older people can that are in the
club scene and when they do they succeed
like anybody else
um but
it may be a kind of a thing where
the young person now deals with older
people
face to face in a direct way kind of the
way we do but they may not deal with
their peers like that but they still see
the technique and the truth of what you
showed them now I'm mostly talking about
the guy that I'm talking about the
female that I was talking about in that
example
she kind of didn't make it she she ended
up leaving the scene and running off
with [ __ ] some other guys but I think
they're kind of from from her post
they're
kind of snapping her out of it too older
people can snap younger people out of
that
well the thing about it though
is that I kind of feel like people put
too much
emphasis
on
in-person interaction
as opposed to online interaction
because I kind of feel like those two
things are not that different like if
you're interacting with people in real
time like yeah that's a little bit
different but it's not that different to
interacting with people online I don't I
wouldn't like want to
I don't know I feel like I don't really
want to like disparage like people's
like online because that's kind of like
a relationship too like yeah hanging out
with people online is like like in real
life as opposed to online is different
but it's I don't think it's as different
as people have painted it as all right
uh that's what I'm saying seven to
answer your question yeah coil and
throbbing gristle were good but that's
not early industrial for us I like
skinny puppy all right I like thriving
gristle yeah
further back to like skinny puppy and
early front to four times Robin gristle
was before skinny hey was it okay all
right okay I didn't I didn't know they
went back that far yeah I was in I was
in the skinny puppy Front 242 and then
later on like [ __ ] uh cam lab
Frontline assembly
um
you know that was the unless it was like
later that was later 90s that's what I
mean that was later but not but not
skinny poppy skinny puppy was 80s
throbbing gristle was 70s I didn't know
I never heard of them didn't hurt them
until later
I didn't know about him remember Boaz
back then there was no Internet it's
just depending on what record you found
yeah well I know I know yeah I was there
yeah so I didn't hear about hear about
them until later I knew about uh newborn
students he knew about and I knew about
this I didn't like them that much though
oh I like it I thought it was a little
too noisy
there wasn't much music to it during the
time that I forget like I said it's
experimental like they're experimenting
with other forms which like I said all
the
that was one of the things that I liked
about the whole post-punk movement which
was not only music but it was also like
art and everything like that
everybody was experimenting with like
[ __ ] that hadn't been done before
I'm stars in annoy Mountain were like
we're gonna make music but out of stuff
that you wouldn't make a music I didn't
like them that much I do like them
though I like them but like like I said
they they started out doing like stuff
we're gonna make music out of stuff that
you wouldn't make music out of like you
know pipes and [ __ ] like that but
I have to say like as they progressed
uh blixenberg held you know by the way
was in Nick Cave in the Bad Seeds which
probably my favorite band of all time
the cave and birthday party my favorite
thing
but they kind of like as it went on they
had a album that came out I think it was
in 2004
was it 2004 I want to say
and they had an album that came out back
that were they were kind of like they
went back to like minimalist kind of
stuff and that [ __ ] was
amazing I listen to that like so much it
was so so good it was so good
yeah I mean I was just like really into
it but you know it's you know how you do
I know how you do so
Zach says as much as I love the internet
I feel like it's damaged people's
ability to communicate interpersonally
in some ways I think we addressed that I
thought you read that already yeah I did
it's it I don't know
it did but like I don't know
I guess Victor says the 90s were my
teenage years I [ __ ] love the 90s
fair enough
um I was I turned
um 18 in 1990.
so
the 90s I wanted to like the 90s I did I
did I was excited about it
but then
man I've graduated in 1990 and then like
it seemed like everything just went to
[ __ ] everything went to [ __ ] everything
just went like all the goth [ __ ] that I
loved in the 80s like went all corporate
and went like all corporate and
Industrial like they tried to make
things [ __ ] like high-tech that was
like when [ __ ] [ __ ] deep came out
from [ __ ] uh
Peter Murphy
now that no that was a great album that
sounded corporate to me sorry but it was
1990. yeah it sounded corporate yeah
now I will say that I do prefer his 88
album which was lovely Syria deep was
good too though but after that
yeah it will Peter Murphy from Bauhaus
he was trying to pursue
he wanted some [ __ ] he's like look
all of the Indie [ __ ] is going
mainstream and I'm gonna like cash in on
that
I get it I don't blame him but yeah
that was a good album I'm just I'm not
talking that's a good album that was a
good album it sounded corporate to me
okay well how long we've been how long
we've been going because it's time for
us to get something to eat
3 14. yeah okay hang on Hannah hang on
all right hang on
Jeffy Hart said the 80s were a mixed bag
for me
love the music and pop culture
it was a bad time to be gauge at a rise
of AIDS and homophobia just my
perspective yeah that was always there
well
yeah I kind of feel like like I said I
liked the 80s for a lot of things but
the reason that I wouldn't go back is
just because I didn't love the whole
but growing up goth in the 80s
you kind of you walk in a department
store and everybody thought oh my God
you're like [ __ ] they do that to you
it's like you [ __ ] are you in a
dungeon dragons are you a Satanist I
thought all that [ __ ] was funny it is
funny it is funny but you see what's
worse than all that is that when every
motherfucker's goth all right now now
every [ __ ] in every trailer park
is goth and uh all movies are goth and
now it's all cheapened and [ __ ]
corporate and that was for that was
around for a while okay so we had it we
had that's what that's we had to keep
changing the way we looked that's why I
didn't like that yes we had to keep
changing the way we looked because y'all
was catching up with us all right and
then they try to make that [ __ ]
corporate all right and uh yeah I just
we were trying to be different we
weren't trying to be accepted which was
hilarious like I said
1990 yeah or no 1989 1990. I'm walking
through the mall
dress like I usually dress
and some dude shouts out to me yeah
Lydia yeah which was from Beetlejuice
everybody's trying to be accepted which
came out at 88 yeah and I was just kind
of like [ __ ] I've been dressing like a
long time before Beetlejuice came out
yeah so that's kind of like I don't know
so we got kind of like offended yeah
offended but
look I love Beetlejuice I love it it's
kind of like my boy
laughs
I don't want to offend anybody
everybody's talking about homophobia and
this and that and [ __ ] I'm just
[ __ ] kind of makes me think of
[ __ ] what me and me and Jen went
through [ __ ] we went through it
separately but we weren't trying to be
accepted we didn't want acceptance from
[ __ ] mundanes [ __ ] y'all
we didn't give a [ __ ] about you people
we had we were doing our own thing yeah
and that was like Toby took my buddy
Toby's a [ __ ] leather daddy all right
and when [ __ ] gay [ __ ] bondage and
[ __ ] went mainstream he was like what
the [ __ ] is this he liked it better when
it was someone underground dark [ __ ]
thing yeah he's like anybody could be
gay now now they got these [ __ ]
gay people trying to get married like
they're [ __ ] straight what is this
this the [ __ ] now they want to be
[ __ ] June Cleaver and [ __ ] you guys
are [ __ ] you know he was he was my
he's like [ __ ] you you know he he was
like he liked it when it was not
acceptable because that differentiated
him from the mainstream
that was where his identity was cut he
wasn't trying to be accepted by straight
people because he's like what are you
talking about he's our age why would you
want straight people to accept what you
want what you are and all right people
that are Generations X we didn't give a
[ __ ] we don't like we're not trying to
[ __ ] conform to you right we don't we
don't like conforming of any kind we
don't want so it's like [ __ ] lady
[ __ ] telling oh I love you and [ __ ]
out of here all right this is something
y'all young people have come up with you
know you're trying to get along you know
what I mean it's just laughable to us
you know what I mean we were actually
rebellious we were basically we were
[ __ ] you we didn't want you accepting us
if you accepted us that made us uncool
because y'all [ __ ] sucked yeah if you
said well that's cool that you then we
suck then that's that was the mentality
you know what I mean that's what I mean
it's like kind of like I'm not saying
this like it's better nowadays like just
we're not getting [ __ ] we're not getting
[ __ ] thrown at us in the 80s it was much
cooler like if you were goth or you were
gay or whatever it's like you didn't
want you didn't want their approved
stream to approve of you if they did
that that was late that was the kiss of
death that was like to have them approve
of you I don't really know you wanted
them to [ __ ] on you yeah because then
you could fight back you could fight
back y'all are [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] you know what I mean so I
get it so like scene was a lot closer to
the punk rock scene we were a Counter
Culture we weren't the culture
we were The Counter Culture yeah we
didn't want any parties we don't want
nothing to do well because the
mainstream culture at that time like I
said very lame
so they were not accepting yeah that was
accepting of gay rights they were not
accepting of anything their job their
their purpose in life the mainstream's
purpose in life was to work do jobs do
[ __ ] that we wouldn't do like Trucking
and Drilling and soldiering and do [ __ ]
that we wouldn't do that was their job
and to have children that's their job
we didn't do that they did that
it's like they were working for us
nice
and you all got pussified over times
okay y'all are trying to be accepted by
people that will never be
well look I'm just saying those people
would have never been like me and Jen
never
that's not the way they were anybody all
right back then or nowadays the espouses
any kind of crap yeah
that is like not accepting of
gay people goth people anything like
that
I don't want to [ __ ] hear it you're
like a [ __ ] old person
I'm old
that's old person [ __ ] I'm not
not about it I never really saw the gay
thing as a thing
well that's the thing you were either
cool or you weren't cool
but it has to be a thing because
you know they have to [ __ ] fight for
the same rights that everybody else has
so the fact that we didn't think it was
a big deal yeah I didn't really think it
was a thing we didn't think it was a big
deal yeah but apparently other people
did yeah so you still kind of have to
like stand up for that [ __ ] because
honestly
well there are some straight people that
aren't [ __ ] cool and there are some
great people that aren't cool so that
was that wasn't that was there's a lot
of straight yeah so that wasn't the
deciding factor I didn't care if you
were straight or gay I just cared for
whether or not you were cool or not uh
[ __ ] yeah just don't be a dude yes
because you know I mean I I I really
think it seems like it's not that hard
but apparently it is that hard because
there are a lot of people that are
having problems with it nowadays
a lot of people having problems with not
being a douche yeah I'm sorry if that's
hard for you
okay you uh I don't find it hard let's
shut it down I'm hungry you you talking
to all these people we're gonna come
back
when's the next show Sunday oh yeah okay
Sunday Sunday we're gonna do another
show we're talking about a movie we're
talking about movie and then Monday
we're gonna do uh for the birthday show
and a haunting haunting on a birthday
because Monday's my actual okay so son
we're gonna be back Sunday I'm gonna
feed this woman all right that's what I
said and then I'm gonna feed myself
we're gonna have some of that chicken
salad how is that okay that's not good
or I can cook something else but it's
ready yeah that's fine okay we'll do
that
no shoes asked what do we think of uh
cigar Ross who
the band cigarroth Zig zigger Roth I
don't I don't I've never heard of it I
don't know across the Icelandic never
heard them
I mean I'm sure you've heard them I
never heard them it's a it's a black
metal band
not really
yeah they're good okay have a great
evening guys enjoy your meal happy
birthday Jenny thank you good night all
see everyone on Sunday yeah we don't
know what movie we're going to be
talking about but yeah Victor says
there's a lot of gay people that are
douchebags yeah it's it doesn't really
well there's a lot of people people
it doesn't matter if you're a gay
straight whatever the [ __ ] I I there's a
lot of people that you gotta judge a
[ __ ] for who they are all right
you and it and I'm a very I'm a equal
opportunity hater I well yeah I'm a very
like opportunity I'm gonna meet you
you're right yeah are you a douche right
exactly
yeah you're not going to get free pass
you're gonna get pretty fast you're
either cool you're not I'm but I'm
open-minded you know I mean [ __ ] some
dudes got games some people got game
other people don't they just each person
is an individual situation you're
individuals not groups that's what I
mean you gotta like approach everything
as though it's a it's an individual
situation Tammy Sanders shut this [ __ ]
down Jenny shut this [ __ ] we gotta shut
it down man Hugo's saying it's a great
show we got loaded on moonshine
uh [ __ ] out here you're gonna switch to
miss moonshine we didn't even like bust
open the wrong no we got that in the
next show
next show next show and here I'll give
you some of that and then I'll go down
there and cook
and then we'll watch some movies or
something before we fall asleep
I already hit that [ __ ] earlier so I'll
[ __ ] tonight you're off a hook
Emma you're off the hook tonight yeah
all right so I can just like lay down
yeah you can rest he's telling me yeah
yeah yeah I'm gonna come back on you by
tomorrow the next day well thank you for
watching yeah thank you very much
because okay schedule that [ __ ] because
man we had a whole situation we had a
whole situation
all right it's all right okay we're
gonna shut this [ __ ] there okay
go ahead
let's see she's into the game she plays
I'm not playing the game I just thought
that was funny things about it all right
so Sunday we'll be talking about some
movie I don't know which one Monday is
my birthday but we're gonna be talking
about a haunting episode on that
so thank you everybody for hanging out
with us this Friday evening thank you
for all your super chats very much
appreciated we will see you again on
Sunday
and good night you guys have a good
weekend good night